İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 30 Ekim 2024 çarşamba günü 36. ders günümüz saat 19.31.
Pazartesi gününkü ders için özür diliyorum. Hiç beklenmedik bir şekilde olaylar gelişti.
Son anda iptal etmek zorunda kaldım. Kusura bakmayın.
Dersimize başlayacağız. Kaldığınız yerden devam edeceğiz.
Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerler arkadaşlar.
Şimdi efendim nerede kaldığımızı şöyle bir hatırlayalım.
Konu başlığımız halen templitler, halen templitler konusunda devam ediyoruz.
Jenerik programlama paradigmasında modern C++'la dile eklenen en önemli araçlardan biri variatik templitler.
Her ne kadar kullanılan terim bu olsa da, konuya hemen kaldığımız yerden bir giriş yapalım.
Burada kast edilen templitlerin parametrelerinin bir paket şeklinde olması.
Buna ne deniyordu?
Templit parametre paketi.
Bir template parametre paketi küre ilişkin, type'a ilişkin yani type parametre pak,
değeri ilişkin non-type parametre pak ya da template-templit parametre pak olabilir.
Yani her template parametre tipi için bir parametre paketi oluşturmak mümkün.
Sandbox nasıldı?
Type name ya da class anahtar sözcüğünden sonra elipsiz ve pakete verilen isim.
Eğer burada type name ya da class anahtar sözcüğünü kullanırsanız, type parametre pak yine eğer bir tür kullanırsanız örneğin int bu non-type parametre pak.
Ne demek bir parametre paketi?
Yani bu parametre paketinde sıfır dahil en tane template parametresi olabilir.
Örneğin buraya class anahtar sözcüğünü yazarsam, ilk örneğe geri dönelim.
Bu bir sınıf şablonu olsun, class, my class.
Şimdi my class sınıf şablonundan variadik parametre paketine sahip olduğu için, parametre paketine sahip olduğu için
böyle bir sınıfta oluşturabilirim, böyle bir sınıfta oluşturabilirim.
Efendim buraya en tane tür argümanı yazabilirim.
Eğer örneğin şöyle bir tür oluşturursam, int double long, tabii ki bunlar herhangi bir tür argümanı olabilir.
Bu durumda pakette üç tane parametre var demek.
Parametre paketinde üç tane template tür parametresi var demek.
İşte değerli arkadaşlar, bu parametre paketindeki türlere erişmek için bir takım ifadeler kullanıyorduk.
Bunlara expansion deniyor dedi.
Tam da zaten orada kalmıştık.
Yalnız bir şeye dikkat.
Şimdi parametre paketinin olması, template parametre paketinin olması sınıf şablonu ya da değişken şablonu ya da fonksiyon şablonu olmasıyla ilgili değil.
Örneğin bu bir fonksiyon şablonu da olabilir.
Fonksiyon şablonu olduğunda eğer template parametre paketinden sonra bu kez elipsiz token'a gelirse,
arkadaşlar bu durumda bu da fonksiyonun parametre paketi.
Template parametre paketi başka, fonksiyon parametre paketi başka.
Başka, birbiriyle ilişkili ama ikisi aynı olmak zorunda değil.
Mesela ben bu fonksiyona çağrı yaparken,
yine diğer fonksiyon şablonlarında olduğu gibi
explicit template argümanı kullanabilirim ya da didakçından, tür çıkarımından faydalanabilirim.
Örneğin funk'ı bu şekilde çağırırsam, 1, 4, 7, 2.3, fonksiyona dört tane argüman gönderdiğim için fonksiyonun dört tane parametre değişkeni olacak.
Her biri için çıkarım yapılacak.
Template parametre paketinde de, tür parametre paketinde de dört tür olacak.
Yani örneğin fonksiyonu böyle çağırmak, aslında funk'ı hangi specialization'ı çağırmak demek?
Funk, int, int, efendim üçüncüsü yine int, dördüncüsü double.
Derleyicinin oluşturduğu fonksiyonunda doğal olarak dört tane parametre değişkeni var dedik değil mi?
Yani kafanızda canlandırın, derleyicinin oluşturduğu specialization, instantiation daha doğrusu asla nasıl bir fonksiyon olacak?
Sanki int türden birinci parametre, int türden ikinci parametre, int türden üçüncü parametre ve double türden dördüncü parametre.
Şimdi işte bütün mesele, özellikle fonksiyon çablonlarında bunun bize sağlayacağı olanaklar ve bu parametre değişkenlerinin nasıl kullanılacağı üstünde epey bir vakit harcayacağız.
Arkadaşlar baştan söyledim, şimdi template'ler o kadar geniş bir konu ki anlat anlat bitmez.
Biz önce en önemli sentaks özelliklerinden başlayarak yavaş yavaş detaya gidiyoruz.
Yani daha çok da detaya gitmiş değiliz kursun süresi göz önüne alındığında.
Arkadaşlar birden fazla template parametre paketi olabilir mi?
Geçen bir arkadaşım da bu soruyu sormuştu.
Olabilir, yani teknik olarak olamaz değil.
Belirli template'lerde sorunun cevabı net olamaz.
Örneğin sınıf şablonlarında.
Örneğin şöyle bir sınıf şablonu oluşturmak isteseniz.
Diyelim ki template, type name, efendim, A.
Büyük harf genelde tercih ediliyor.
Evet, type name, B.
Şimdi bu zaten doğrudan template'i oluştururken sentaks hatası.
Hemen görüyorsunuz yardımcı program altını çizdi.
İki, yine sınıf şablonları için en sondaki template parametresi, parametre paketi olabilir.
Yani şunu da yazamam açıkçası.
Fakat fonksiyon şablonlarında biraz daha esneklik var.
Yani fonksiyon şablonlarında ne parametre paketi bir tane olmak zorunda,
ne de parametre paketi en son parametre olmak zorunda.
tamamen duruma göre eğer template parametre paketindeki parametrelere karşılık gelen argümanlar anlaşılıyorsa,
müsaade ediliyor.
Bir örnek vermek gerekirse,
Mesela bakınız, template type name yine x, type name y,
tabi klas anahtar sözcüğünü de kullanabilirdim,
void bu.
Bakın şu anda aldığını çizmedi, henüz bir sentaks hatası yok.
x, xarx, şöyle yazalım.
Örneğin int, int, y, yarx.
Halen yardımcı aracın bir sentaks hatası işaretlemediğini görüyorsunuz.
Hemen bu arada size of operatörünü de hatırlayalım.
Yeni size of operatörümüzü.
Eğer size of anahtar sözcüğünden sonra
ellipsis token'ı gelirse,
parantez içinde template parametre paketini ya da fonksiyon parametre paketinin ismini yazarsam,
son by time sabiti olarak pakette kaç argüman olduğu bilgisini
stot size t türünden bir değer olarak elde ediyorum.
Mesela bakınız, stot cout size of x, şöyle yazalım, eşittir size of x.
Bunu kod içinde de kullanmaya yaygın, çok örnek yapacağız.
Yeni aynı şekilde size of y, size of y.
Template kodun derlenmesinde bir sentaks hatası olmadığını görüyorsunuz.
Şimdi birinci parametre, template parametre paketi olduğu için
örneğin ekspresit olarak argümanları şöyle yazarsam,
int, double, int, arkadaşlar izleyin.
Zaten bu argümanlar birinci parametre paketine gidecek.
Yani burada illegal bir şey yok.
Fonksiyon çağrı operatörü, örneğin bir, iki, üç, takip edin,
dört, beş, altı, yedi, sekiz, dokuz, hadi bu kadar olsun.
Şimdi bu durumda, şunlar birinci parametre paketine gidecek.
Dolayısıyla fonksiyonun ilk üç parametresine geçinen değerler,
bu da fonksiyonun ilk üç parametresinin int, double, int olduğu anlamına geliyor.
Bu durumda fonksiyonun kodundaki şu sabit,
üç sabit olacak.
Diğer iki parametreye,
yani birinci parametre paketinden sonra gelen parametrelere,
sırasıyla onlara beş ve beş değerleri gelecek.
Geriye kalanlar da ikinci pakete gidecek.
Eğer bir yanlışlık yapmadıysa,
runtime'da gösterelim arkadaşlar.
Bakın,
birinci parametre paketinde,
üç tane parametre var.
İkinci parametre paketinde,
dört tane parametre var.
Hatta burada şöyle bir kural dahi var arkadaşlar.
Şimdi fonksiyon şablonları söz konusu olduğu zaman,
variyadik parametre paketi ikiye ayırıyor standart.
Trailing ya da non-trailing diye.
Şimdi,
trailing olması,
en son parametre olması demek.
Ama non-trailing olması,
en son parametre olmaması demek.
Fonksiyona çağrı yaptığımız zaman,
eğer eksplisit argüman kullanmazsak,
örneğin çağrıyı şöyle yaparsam,
arkadaşlar,
bu durumda,
birinci parametre paketi boş kabul ediliyor.
Argümanlar,
ondan sonraki öğelere dağıtılıyor.
Bu da,
standartın koyduğu bir kural.
Dolayısıyla arkadaşımız sorusunun cevabı,
evet,
duruma göre bu örnekte olduğu gibi,
birden fazla parametre paketi olabilir.
Yalnız bir şeye dikkat,
fonksiyon şablonlarına.
Tabii bu,
çok daha seyrek karşımıza çıkacak bir senaryo.
Senaryoların,
çok büyük çoğunluğunda,
özellikle fonksiyon şablonlarında,
sadece,
bir tane parametre paketi olacak.
Ama tabii fonksiyonun,
birden fazla parametre paketi olabilir.
Birden fazla parametresi olabilir.
Mesela,
şöyle kafamızı da canlandıralım.
En çok karşımıza çıkacak senaryoları.
Burada fonksiyonun,
bir tane parametre paketi var.
Ve,
temput parametre paketi var,
fonksiyonun da bir tane parametre paketi var.
Ama örneğin şöyle de olabilir.
Bu durumda,
fonksiyonun iki parametresi var.
Birincisi normal parametre,
ikincisi parametre paketi.
Hem put parametre sayısı da,
bir daha fazla olabilir.
Mesela,
böyle olsaydı,
arkadaşlar,
P türünden,
X,
E,
S,
Arx,
özellikle bu yapıya dikkat.
Örneğin,
ben bu fonksiyonu şöyle çağırdığımda,
Fonksiyona gönderilen,
hem birinci argüman için,
hem de diğer argümanlar için,
çıkarım yapılacak.
Birinci argüman,
fonksiyonun birinci parametresine gönderildiği için,
o da birinci template,
tür parametresinden olduğu için,
P karşılığı kullanılan tür,
int olacak.
Ama geriye kalanlar,
pakete gidecek.
Bu durumda,
template parametre paketinde,
üç tane parametre,
ve buna karşılık da,
fonksiyonun üç ilave,
parametre değişkeni,
daha olacak.
Arkadaşlar,
bir şey daha göstermek istiyorum.
Bakınız,
geçen derslerden birinde göstermiştim.
Şimdi,
GCC derleyicisinde,
bu makro,
pretty function,
visual studio'da,
underscore underscore,
func,
signature'da.
Şimdi bu makro,
fonksiyonun,
geri dönüş değeri dahil,
parametrelerine de işaret eden,
bir yazıya açılıyor.
Yani örneğin,
ben şöyle bir kod yazarsam,
bazı konuları daha iyi anlamak için,
arkadaşlar,
derleyicinin oluşturduğu,
instantiation'ın,
nasıl bir fonksiyonu olduğunu,
görebilirim.
Bakın şimdi,
izleyin,
C declaration'ı görmeyin,
foo'nun,
int virgül,
char virgül,
double açılımı.
Bu durumda,
birinci int,
birinci parametre paketi,
birinci template parametresi için,
ve diğerleri,
yani,
int, char ve double,
parametre paketine gidiyor.
Yani bazı karmaşık durumların,
üstesinden gelmek için,
arka planda ne oluyor,
bunu görmek için,
ilave bir yazım kullanmıyorsanız,
creative function,
ya da funcic makrosunu,
kullanabilirsiniz.
Şimdi geldik,
en kritik yere.
Arkadaşlar,
bu konunun,
en kritik kısmı,
İngilizce,
tech expansion,
dediğimiz,
yapı.
Tech expansion,
paketin genişletilmesi,
diye belki Türkçe'ye çevrilebilir.
biraz kapa ama ben paketin patlatılması da diyorum,
patlat paketi.
Arkadaşlar,
öyle bir ifade ki,
derleyici,
ilgili kontekste,
belirli örüntülere uygun olarak,
burada örüntüsü,
sözcüğünde Türkçe,
İngilizce pattern sözcüğünün karşılığı olarak kullanıyorum,
virgüllerle ayrılan listeye dönüştürüyor.
şimdilik şu parametreyi yok edelim,
ve buradan tekrar başlayalım.
Arkadaşlar,
tech expansion'ı,
template parametre paketi içinde,
fonksiyon parametre paketi içinde kullanabilirsiniz.
Eğer,
template parametre paketinin,
isminden sonra,
bu sefer elipsizin yerine bakın,
elipsiz token'ını koyarsanız,
derleyici bunu,
paketteki,
sürülerin,
isimlerini içeren,
virgüllerle ayrılan bir listeye,
çeviriyor.
Yani bu ne demek?
Örneğin,
arkadaşlar,
diyelim ki,
henüz bizim tanışmadığımız,
ama C++'ın,
jenerik programlama tarafında,
özellikle en sık kullanılan sınıflarından biri,
sınıf şablonlarından biri olan,
Google sınıfına bakın.
Şimdi ben,
bu tuple'ın,
int,
virgül,
double,
açılımı deseydim,
bu arada,
tuple'ın kendi site variyetlik parametre paketine sahip,
tuple sınıf şablonunun,
öyle bir instant station'ını oluşturacak giderleyici,
parametre paketinde,
iki tane türü var.
ama şimdi bakınız,
eğer ben şöyle yazarsam,
es,
burada,
parametre paketindeki parametreler,
int,
double,
long ise,
derleyicinin oluşturduğu,
fonksiyon kodunda,
tuple'ın,
int,
double,
long açılımı,
söz konusu olacak.
yani,
parametre paketi,
template parametre paketi,
expand edildiğinde,
parametre paketindeki,
türler,
ya da değerlerden oluşan,
comma separated liste dönüşüyor.
işte bu örneğin,
başka bir template'in,
explicit template argümanları olarak kullanılabilir.
Yeri geldiğinde,
ilk değer verme listesi olarak kullanılabilir.
Arkadaşlar,
avant sınıflarının listesi olabilir,
olabilir de olabilir.
Fakat daha da önemlisi,
şimdi burayı biraz daha dikkatli izlemelisiniz,
eğer parametre paketi,
template parametre paketi değil de,
fonksiyon parametre paketi,
hack extension dediğimiz,
örüntüye,
ya da örüntülerden birine tabi tutulursa,
bu da aslında derleyici tarafından,
neye dönüştürülüyor?
Buraya dikkat.
Şimdi bu fonksiyon,
parametre paketinde,
üç tane parametre varsa,
şimdi kafanızda canlandırmaya çalışın.
Aslında fonksiyon şöyle değil mi?
T1 türünden,
E1 bir tür,
parametre P1,
P2 türünden,
parametre P2,
P3 türünden,
parametre P3.
Örneğin,
template parametre paketinde,
üç tane tür varsa,
şimdi ben,
eğer,
çok iyi izliyorsunuz,
template parametre paketini ekspant edersem,
aslında o neye dönüşecek?
E1,
E2,
P3,
yukarı.
E1,
E2,
E3,
böyle bir listeye dönüşecek.
Fakat,
eğer,
burada olduğu gibi,
fonksiyon parametre paketini ekspant edersem,
o zaman da bu,
aslında,
nasıl bir listeye dönüştürülecek?
P1,
P2,
P3.
Buraya kadar takip edebildik mi?
Dolayısıyla,
virgüllerle ayrılan liste kullanılan birçok kontekste,
ne yapabiliyorum?
Parametre paketinin ekspant edilmiş halini,
kullanabiliyorum.
Mesela birkaç tane örnek vereyim.
Herkes de katkı izliyor.
Altının çizmesine de bakmayın.
Örneğin,
bari isimli bir fonksiyonu olsaydı,
ve ben bari bu şekilde çağırsaydım,
bu durumda bar fonksiyonla,
bu arada barın kendisi de bir fonksiyon şablonu olabilir.
Aslında,
kimin değerlerini göndermiş olacaktım olsam,
fonksiyonun,
parametre değişkeninin,
değişkenlerinin değerlerini göndermiş olacaktım.
Burayı anladık mı?
Evet, bravo çağrı.
P1,
P2,
P3.
Yalnız burası,
biraz daha karmaşık.
Neden?
Pek Expansion,
arkadaşlar,
bir ne de olabilir?
Daha uzun bir örüntü de olabilir.
Mesela,
paternin kendisinde,
adres operatörü olsaydı,
bu sefer de,
derleyici bunu neye dönüştürecekti?
Mehmet Can,
şuna dönüştürecekti.
Bar,
diyelim ki,
fonksiyonun birinci parametresi,
adres P1,
fonksiyonun ikinci parametresi,
adres P2,
üçüncü parametresi,
adres P3,
bu sefer de böyle bir listeye dönüştürecekti.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Ama,
şimdi bakın özellikle arkadaşlar,
bu,
Arx,
burada,
dikkat ederseniz,
Elipsis,
Arx,
parametre paketi ismini izlemiyor.
Bunu izliyor.
Dolayısıyla,
burada,
Expansion nasıl yapılacak,
tahmin edebilir misiniz?
Zaten birkaç tane örnek görünce,
hepsini tahmin etmeniz çok zor olmuyor.
Aslında şuna dönüştürecek,
Bar'a,
argüman olarak,
Fu P1,
virgül,
Fu P2,
Fu P3.
Yani aslında,
Fu fonksiyonuna,
gönderilen,
bizim fonksiyonumuzun,
arkadaşlar,
Fu olmasın,
Bar'a,
şununla barışmasın,
baz olsun.
Evet,
bu durumda,
Bar fonksiyonu,
Fu fonksiyonundan,
Fu fonksiyonuna yapılan çağrılardan,
elde edilen,
geri dönüş değerleriyle,
çağrılacak.
Şimdi ben,
Hack Expansion'a,
birkaç tane örnek vereceğim.
Ama,
çok sayıda,
örnek,
üstünden geçebilmemiz için,
kodları tek tek yazmam,
çok iyi bir fikir olmaz.
O yüzden,
küçük küçük açıklamalarla,
yazdığım kodları,
buraya yapıştıracağım.
Arkadaşlar,
ama,
biraz sabırlı olmamız gerekiyor.
İzleyin.
Şimdi,
önce buraya bir bakalım,
sevgili arkadaşlar.
Ve,
burada,
neler görüyoruz?
Bir,
konuşalım.
Bu arada,
evet,
C++ 17'ye almışız en son,
tekrar,
düzeltelim.
Şimdi,
soru bir.
Bu ne?
Bu,
C++ 20 ile gelen,
Abbreviated Template Syntax.
Eğer bu,
kafanızı karıştırıyorsa,
o zaman,
şöyle de yazabilirim.
böyle yazmakla,
PS,
ARX,
aynı şey.
O zaman,
şimdilik orayla kafanızı karıştırmayalım.
Çok güzel.
Arkadaşlar,
bu bir fonksiyon şablonu,
ve fonksiyon şablonunun,
hem tek parametre paketi var,
hem fonksiyon parametre paketi var.
ama,
sizin şu anda şunu bilmeniz yeterli,
konuyla ilgili.
Bu fonksiyon,
kendisine gönderilen argümanları,
standart output'a yazdırıyor,
sonra da bir new line veriyor.
Bunu nasıl yaptığını,
şimdilik konuşmayacağız.
Yine aynı şekilde,
bu da aslında,
template type name'de,
bu demek.
Bunu da geçtik.
Ve bu da aynı şekilde,
template type name,
arkadaşlar,
TS,
ARX demek.
Şimdi buraya kadar,
sanırım olay netleşti.
Bu,
bir fonksiyon şablonunun,
nasıl çalıştığını bilmiyoruz,
ama kendisine gönderilen,
argümanların hepsini,
standart output'a yazdırıyor.
Bu tek parametreli bir,
fonksiyon şablonu,
kendisine gönderilen,
adresi,
böyle bir return ifadesine kullanıyor.
Beni ilgilendiren şimdi burası,
diğerlerini yardımcı arası olarak kullanıyorum.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi sadece F'ye,
bakın,
diğerlerini görmeyin.
Bunların her biri,
satırdaki,
elipsisle oluşturulan ifadelerin,
her biri bir,
pek eksperşen.
Şimdi ben size tek tek soracağım.
Zaten bir çoğunu tahmin edebileceksiniz.
Soru bir,
bu neye açılacak?
Burada,
herhangi bir pattern olmadığı için,
print fonksiyonuna,
fonksiyonumuzun parametrelerine,
argüman olarak göndereceğiz.
Burayı anladık mı?
Yani,
f'i,
x,
y,
z ile çağırdığımda,
fonksiyonun,
üç tane int parametresi var.
Ve bu parametreler,
yukarıdaki print fonksiyon çablonuna,
argüman olarak gönderecek.
Dolayısıyla,
o fonksiyon çablonu da,
bizim argümanlarımızın,
değerlerini yazdırdığına göre,
gördüğünüz gibi,
değerler yazıldı.
Eğer böyle çağırmak yerine,
iki argüman daha verseydim,
herhangi bir şekilde,
bir problem olmayacaktı.
Bu sefer,
bunlar da yazdırılacaktı.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Şimdi ikinciye bakalım.
İkinci de,
az önce söylediğim gibi,
Ater'nin kendisi,
adres args.
O zaman,
derleyici bunu,
neye dönüştürecek?
Söyleyin.
Adres p1,
adres p2,
bu şekilde,
bir listeye,
dönüştürecek.
Dolayısıyla,
print fonksiyonu da bu durumda,
aldığı argümanları,
print ettiğine göre,
gönderdiğim,
adresleri,
yazdırmış olacak.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Tabii,
arkadaşlar,
bir şeye dikkat edin.
Buradaki adresler,
F'e gönderdiğim argümanlar değil,
parametre değişkenlerinin adresleri.
Dolayısıyla,
aslında,
standart alpuda yazılacak bütün değerler,
int nesne adresleri.
Değil mi?
Evet.
Bakın.
Devam.
Bunu da geçtik.
şimdi üçüncüye gelelim.
Evet.
Bu sayıyı da biraz azaltalım.
Lütfen dikkat.
Peki,
burada pater ne?
10 çarpı args.
Peki,
bu durumda,
derdeyici bunu,
neye dönüştürecek?
Arkadaşlar,
10 çarpı P1,
virgül,
10 çarpı P2,
10 çarpı P3.
Dolayısıyla,
print fonksiyonuna gönderilen argümanlar,
bu durumda,
1, 2, 3 değil,
10,
20,
ve 30 olacak.
Takip edebildik mi?
Bravo.
Bakın.
10,
20,
30.
Devam.
Buraya özellikle dikkat.
Bakın,
tahmin edebilecek misiniz?
Burada pater,
args çarpı args.
Dolayısıyla,
P1 çarpı P1,
virgül,
P2 çarpı P2 virgül,
P3 çarpı P3 virgül.
Dolayısıyla,
gönderilen argümanların,
karesi yazdırılacak.
Şimdi,
paternimiz,
biraz daha karmaşık hale geliyor.
İzleyin.
Bu durumda,
değerli arkadaşlar,
derdeyici bunu,
neye dönüştürecek?
Yanıt,
G,
adres P1,
virgül,
arkadaşlar,
G,
adres P2,
virgül,
G,
adres P3.
G'nin kendisi de bir fonksör çamlını olduğuna göre,
bu aldığı adresteki nesnenin karesi,
artı 10 değerini döndürüyor.
Dolayısıyla,
arkadaşlar,
bizim gönderdiğimiz nesnelerin karesi artı 10,
ne olur?
11,
arkadaşlar,
14 ve 19,
değil mi?
Yanlış mı hesapladım?
Evet.
Bakın,
11,
14,
19,
bunu da geçtik.
burada ise,
herhalde bu da açık,
neye dönüştürecek?
Artı artı P1,
artı artı P2,
artı artı P3.
Dolayısıyla,
print fonksiyonuna gönderdiğim değerler,
aslında öne kartı artı artı artı operatörünün ürettiği değerler,
dolayısıyla nesnelerin değerlerinin bir fazlası.
takip edebildik mi?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
pek expansion'in üstünde çalışıyoruz.
İkinci örnek,
anlamadığınız bir yer olduğu zaman tekrar edelim.
Şimdi,
ikinci önemli uyarı,
şimdiye kadar,
yazdığım fonksiyon şablonu örneklerinde,
biz hep,
template parametre paketini,
doğrudan,
referans semantiği olmadan,
bu şekilde kullandık.
Şimdi bakınız,
eğer burada,
referans dektaratörü olsaydı,
bu durumda fonksiyonun bütün parametreleri,
L-value referansı olacaktı.
Yani,
parametre paketinde,
int double string varsa,
derleyicinin oluşturduğu instantiation'da,
int ref,
double ref,
string ref,
parametreleri olacak.
Eğer burada const anahtar sözcü olsaydı,
bu sefer fonksiyonun bütün parametreleri,
const L-value referansı olacaktı.
Arkadaşlar,
burada,
ref ref dektaratörü olsaydı,
geçen dersimizi hatırlayın,
bu durumda da,
fonksiyonun bütün parametreleri,
universal referansı olacaktı.
Yani örneğin,
parametre paketinde,
iki tane template parametresi varsa,
bu durumda,
iki tane ne olacak?
Universal referansı,
parametre olacak.
yani parametre paketi,
ya hepsi L-value referans,
ya hepsi universal referans,
ya hepsi R-value referans,
olmak zorunda.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Yine,
constluk da aynı şekilde,
hepsini birden,
niteliyor.
Şimdi,
ikinci örneğe bakalım.
Hadi bakalım.
İzleyin.
Arkadaşlar,
burada,
sizin sadece bilmeniz gereken kısmı söylüyorum.
Buraları henüz anlatmadım ama,
birazdan detaylı anlatacağım.
Square ve sum,
bunlar birlikte kullanılmak üzere,
buradaki ifadeye,
fold expression deniyor.
Bunların hiçbiri henüz görmedik.
Bugün görmeye başlayacağız.
Bu bir.
Fakat sizi ilgilendiren şu,
sum bir fonksiyon şablonunun ismi,
bu fonksiyon şablonu,
kendisine gönderilen,
argümanların toplamını döndürüyor.
Nasıl yaptığı sizi ilgilendirmiyor şimdilik.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Yani örneğin ben,
sum'u şöyle çağırsaydım,
sum,
1,
4,
6,
bunların toplamını döndürecekti.
Yani,
11 değerini döndürecekti arkadaşlar.
Önemli olan,
bu örneği hazırlama nedenim,
buradaki,
hack expansion'ları görmemiz.
Yukarıdakiler önemli değil.
Arkadaşlar,
col-sum içinde,
parametre paketi,
yine expand edilmiş.
Hem fonksiyon parametre paketi.
Dolayısıyla,
ben bu fonksiyonu ilk haline girelim,
böyle çağırdığımda,
aslında bu noktada,
sum'u da,
fonksiyonun parametre değişkenlerinin değerleriyle,
yani 1,
2,
3,
4,
5 değerleriyle çağırmış olacağım.
Dolayısıyla,
15 değerini döndürecek.
Yazdırdığım zaman,
15 değerinin yazdırıldığını göreceksiniz.
Deniyorum.
ikinciye gelelim.
İkinci de ise,
buraya dikkat,
parametre paketi,
expand edildiğinde,
virgürlerle ayrılmış bir isteğe dönüşüyor.
Ama burada bir de,
85 argümanı var.
Dolayısıyla,
sum fonksiyonuna,
sadece 1,
2,
3,
4,
5'i değil,
fonksiyonun ilk parametresine de,
85 değerini göndermiş olacağım.
Dolayısıyla,
85 artı 15,
100 değerini döndürecek.
Yine üçüncü örneğe bakın.
Üçüncü örnekte ise,
pattern,
square args olduğu için,
derleyici,
zaten yanına yazmışım,
şöyle bir listeye dönüştürecek.
Dolayısıyla,
bu sefer fonksiyonu,
square fonksiyonunda kare döndürdüğü için,
arkadaşlar,
1'in,
2'nin,
3'ün,
4'ün,
5'in,
karelerinin toplamı hesaplanmış.
Ve o değer yazdırılmış olacak.
Yani,
25 artı 16,
arkadaşlar,
artı 9,
artı 2,
artı 1.
Evet.
Şimdi,
hemen sırada,
cppref.com'dan bir örnek var.
Güzel bir örnek.
Hatta ben,
kitaba koyarken,
cppref.com'dan olan örnekleri de,
özellikle linkini veriyorum.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın şimdi,
burada,
g isimli fonksiyona,
çare yapıldığında,
main fonksiyonu içinde,
g fonksiyonu da,
f'ye çağrı yapıyor.
Şimdi çok dikkatli izleyelim.
g'ye,
gönderdiğim argümanlara bakın,
1,
0.2,
string literal,
a,
a.
Arkadaşlar,
bu durumda,
g fonksiyonu,
f'yi bu şekilde çağırdığında,
f'ye,
neleri göndermiş oluyor?
Parametre değişkenlerin adreslerini.
Şimdi,
bu sefer de,
f fonksiyonunun,
parametre paketindeki türleri,
ve fonksiyonun parametrelerinin,
ne olacağını söyleyebilir misiniz?
Cevap tabi,
int yıldız,
double yıldız,
ama,
bu da,
arkadaşlar,
conschar yıldız olduğu için,
conschar yıldız türünden,
bir değişkenin adresi olan tür,
conschar,
yıldız yıldız olacak.
Espriyi anladınız mı?
Burada özellikle,
aslında,
gönderilen argümanın,
ve template parametre paketindeki,
türlerin ne olduğunu,
çok güzel göstermiş.
Tekrar edelim mi?
g'yi çağırdığımda,
g'nin parametreleri,
int double conschar yıldız olacak.
Ama,
g'yi içinde f çağrıldığında,
bu sefer de,
burada,
adreslerle,
pack expansion yapıldığı için,
f'nin parametreleri de,
bu durumda,
int için int yıldız,
double için double yıldız,
conschar yıldız için de,
conschar yıldız yıldız olacak.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
tabii,
açılım daha karmaşık da olabilir.
Mesela şu örneğe bakın.
Bu,
bütün örüntüleri başta tek tek,
ezberlemeniz mümkün olmayabilir.
Yine,
yukarıdaki iki fonksiyon çablonunu görmeyin.
Sizi ilgilendiren,
sum'ın,
kendisine gönderilen argümanları topluyor olması,
multiplication'dan ismi verilen malın da,
kendisine gönderilen argümanların çarpımını döndürmesi.
Şimdi espriye bakın.
13. satırda tanıma başlayan,
fu isimli fonksiyon çablonunda,
return ifadesindeki,
pack extension'a bakın.
Arkadaşlar,
burada,
args parametre paketi,
fonksiyon parametre paketi,
expand edilmiş.
Ama,
burada da parametre paketi var.
Bu da expand edilmiş.
Takip edebiliyor musunuz?
Dolayısıyla,
arkadaşlar,
bu durumda,
iki tane pack expansion,
birlikte karşılıklı olarak ele alınacak.
Şimdi fonksiyona,
1, 2, 4 değerlerini gönderdiğimde,
buradaki açılım şöyle olacak.
Arkadaşlar,
sum,
1, 2, 4,
artı 1,
sum,
1, 2, 4,
artı 2,
sum,
1, 2, 4,
artı 4.
Yani,
parametre paketi,
birden fazla kez de,
yine ifade içinde,
expand edilebilir.
Hatta,
hatta,
farklı parametre paketleri de,
karşılıklı expand edilebilir.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Arkadaşlar,
bakın,
bunun en tipik örneği,
perfect forwarding uygulamaları.
Şimdi,
izleyin.
Geçenlerde yazdığımız,
kod,
şimdi çok daha açık hale gelecek.
Şöyle bir kod yazmıştık,
hatırlıyor musunuz?
template type name t.
Şimdi bakın,
pek expansion'ı en güzel gösteren örneklerden,
biri aslında.
Template type name t.
Type name.
Arx.
Make,
şimdi herkes bu örneği hatırlayacak.
Unique.
Fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri,
tut,
unique.
PTR'ın,
P açılımı.
Ve fonksiyonun parametrelerine bakın.
Arx,
refref,
Arx.
Bu durumda,
bu fonksiyonun bütün parametreleri,
Arwell'in referansı değil,
universal referansı.
yani ben bu fonksiyona kaç tane argüman gönderirsem,
argümanların her biri,
universal referanslara gidiyor.
Ona yönelik kurallar geçerli olacak.
koda bakın,
koda bakın şimdi,
nif ifadesiyle,
t türünden bir nesne oluşturuyorum,
ve konstruktora,
eğer,
şöyle,
arkadaşlar,
bir çağrı yapsaydım,
fonksiyonun parametre değişkenlerini göndermiş olurdum.
Zaten bu durumda fonksiyonun parametre değişkenleri,
ya L value referans,
ya R value referansı olacak.
Eğer şöyle yazsaydım,
ismi,
F olan,
fonksiyona argümanları gönderip,
parametre değişkenlerini gönderip,
onların oluşturduğu,
virgüllerle ayrılan listeyi de,
T sınıfının konstruktörün argümanı olarak göndermiş olurdu.
E şimdi,
burada,
P yerine,
bu sefer standart kütüphanenin,
stut forward fonksiyonunu çağırırsam,
eğer stut forward'ın kendisi,
bir fonksiyon şablonu olmasaydı,
template argümanının,
ne olduğunu belirtmek zorunda kalmasaydım,
bu durumda,
her bir argüman stut forward'a gönderilecekti.
Ama şimdi,
bakınız,
bu durumda,
nasıl bir açılım yapılacak,
eğer parametre paketinde,
3 tane parametre varsa,
3 kez stut forward'a çağrı yapılacak.
Birinci de,
arkadaşlar,
burada,
parametre paketindeki birinci tür,
birinci argüman,
fonksiyon parametre paketinde,
virgül,
ikinci tür,
ikinci argüman,
zaten perfect forward'ing'i,
gerçekten de mükemmelleştiren,
buradaki yapı.
Buraya kadar olan kısmı,
şöyle bir gösterelim.
Mesela fonksiyonun,
arkadaşlar,
derleyici tarafından yazılan fonksiyonu,
kafanızda canlandırın.
hatta şöyle,
yavaş yavaş bitelim.
Mesela,
make unique,
my class bir sınıf olsun,
ve diyelim ki,
arkadaşlar,
burada da,
argümanlar,
x, y,
10 olsun.
Şimdi,
derleyici bunu,
neye dönüştürecek?
Arkadaşlar,
stot forward,
x'in türü,
template argümanı,
x,
virgül,
stot forward,
açısal parantez içinde,
y'nin türü,
y.
Bu da ne demek?
Son derece basit.
Geçen derste gördüğümüz,
perfect forwarding mekanizması,
fonksiyonun bütün,
parametreleri için,
kullanılmış olacak.
Yani,
bizim yazdığımız,
make unique fonksiyonu,
aldığı argümanları,
arkadaşlar,
t sınıfının,
t'nin bir sınıf türü olduğunu düşünelim,
constructor'ın da,
perfect forward edecek.
Perfect forward etmesi ne demek?
Value kategorisini koruyarak,
constant'u koruyarak,
gönderecek.
E zaten fonksiyonun da böyle olduğunu,
göstermiştik daha önce.
Sadece aradaki fark ne?
işte bu,
buradan t yıldız türünden,
bir adres elde ediliyor.
Aslında,
unique ptr sınıfının da,
böyle bir pointer parametreli,
nesi var arkadaşlar,
kontraktörü var.
ve burada,
bu konstruktörle,
bir pr value nesne oluşturuyorum.
Dolayısıyla burada da yine,
daha önce öğrendiğimiz,
mandatory copy illusion gerçekleşiyor.
işte,
parametre paketinin,
ya da fonksiyon parametre paketinin,
expand edilmesine yönelik,
örnekler verdik.
Arkadaşlar,
yine sınıflarla ilgili,
verdiğimiz örneklerin hepsini,
çok hızlı bir şekilde görelim.
Sınıf şablonlarında da olabilir.
Mesela burada,
Warren kendisi de bir sınıf şablonu,
Michael's'ın kendisi de bir sınıf şablonu.
O zaman,
ben Michael's'ın int virgül double açılımını,
oluşturduğum zaman,
Michael's'ın int virgül double açılımı,
aslında,
burada virgüllerle ayrılmış liste olduğu için,
bu arada bakın,
expansion'a,
tabii ki buradaki public de dahil,
public dahil olmasaydı,
sadece ilk sınıf ne olurdu?
Arkadaşlar,
public base class olurdu,
diğerleri,
protected olurdu.
Dolayısıyla,
şimdi bizim sınıfımızın taban sınıfı,
arkadaşlar,
ne olacak?
Warren,
yani yukarıdaki sınıf şablonunun,
int double açılımı olacak.
Yine aynı şekilde,
sınıfın public bölümünde,
size t türünden,
statik veri elemanında,
ilk değerini,
size of,
değişken size of operatörüyle,
varianic size of operatörüyle,
değerini,
aldığını,
görüyorsunuz.
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
tabii,
ilerleyen derslerde,
çok fazla örnek yapacağız,
aynı şeyleri de,
tekrar tekrar,
üstünden geçmek de istemiyorum.
Ama,
yavaş yavaş,
konuya gelelim.
Ha,
bu arada bir örnek daha,
belki ilginç bir örnek,
geçen dersimizde,
üstünden,
geçtik mi hatırlamıyorum.
Bakın,
daha karmaşık bir örnek.
Bu sefer,
arkadaşlar,
iki tane parametre paketi var.
Birinci,
hani,
birden fazla parametre paketi olabilir mi,
sorusuna da güzel bir cevap.
Birinci parametre paketi,
template type parametre paketi,
ikinci parametre paketi,
non type parametre paketi.
Arkadaşlar,
fonksiyonun,
parametrelerinin,
nasıl yazıldığına bakın.
Bu durumda,
bu fonksiyonun,
her bir parametresi,
türü t olan,
listeye değil,
diziye,
türü t olan,
boyutu neye olan,
diziye referans.
Doğru mu?
Yani,
örneğin,
fang fonksiyonunu böyle çağırdığımda,
aslında,
fang fonksiyonunun,
hangi specialization'la çağır yapmış oluyorum?
int,
ref,
köşeli parantez,
2,
int,
ref,
arkadaşlar,
bu tabii template vergibene özür dilerim,
int köşeli parantez,
2,
3,
int köşeli parantez,
5,
ve,
double köşeli parantez,
7,
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Bu,
template argümanları.
Fakat,
buna,
çare yaparken,
bu durumda,
fonksiyonun,
parametreleri ne olacak?
İşte,
demin söylediğim gibi,
böyle dizilere,
referans olacak.
Evet,
peki,
arkadaşlar,
yine çok sık karşımıza çıkan yapılardan biri,
parametre paketini,
fonksiyonun içindeki,
yine,
sınıf şablonlarına argüman yapmak.
Mesela şu örneğe bakın.
Sadece benim gösterdiğim yere bakınız.
Arkadaşlar,
burada,
fun fonksiyonunun,
3 tane template parametresi var.
Birinci parametre paket değil,
ikinci parametre paket değil,
üçüncü parametre paket.
Arkadaşlar,
bu durumda örneğin,
13. satırda oluşturduğum,
yerel değişken,
couple sınıf şablonunun,
hangi açılımı?
A,
B,
ve paketteki açılımı.
Yani örneğin,
ben funk'ı bu şekilde çağırdım da,
buraya dikkat.
Parametre paketindeki türler,
int,
float,
double,
long,
çarş.
Dolayısıyla burada,
couple'ın,
int,
float,
double,
long,
çar açılımı türünden,
bir nesne oluşturmuş oluyorum.
İkincide ise,
bu sefer,
parametre paketi,
burada ekspant edilmiş.
Dolayısıyla,
parametre paketindeki türler,
double,
long,
çar olduğu için,
bu sefer de,
tuple'ın,
double,
long,
çar,
int,
float açılımı,
söz konusu olacak.
Ya da buraya bakın,
burada ise,
int,
float,
double,
long,
ve arkadaşlar,
pardon,
söyleyeyim,
int,
double,
long,
çar,
ve float açılımı olacak.
Evet,
şimdi gelelim,
özellikle fonksiyon,
şablonlarında,
parametre paketini nasıl kullanacağım?
şimdi bütün mesele burada.
Yani,
variatik fonksiyon çablonları,
variatik parametre paketine sahip,
fonksiyon çablonları,
dilediğimiz sayıda argümanla,
çağrılma şansı,
olanağı veriyorlar bize.
Ama,
bu olanaktan,
nasıl istifade edeceğiz?
Ona bakalım.
Arkadaşlar,
önce şunu söyleyeyim.
bundan istifade etmek için,
birden fazla teknik var.
Yani,
bütün problem şu,
değil mi?
Sizin bir,
parametre paketiniz var.
Lütfen dikkat edin.
Evet.
Bu da,
diyelim ki,
fonksiyonun,
parametre paketi.
Ve sizin,
böyle bir fonksiyona,
bir iş,
faydalı iş yaptırabilmeniz için,
fonksiyonun,
parametre değişkenlerini,
bir şekilde,
kullanmanız gerekiyor.
Mesela,
bu,
print fonksiyonu olsaydı,
arkadaşlar,
ve,
fonksiyonun,
parametreleri,
const,
lvalue referansı olsaydı,
ve bu fonksiyonun amacı,
kendisine gönderilen,
gönderilen bütün argümanları,
standart output'a yazdırmak olsaydı,
o zaman şöyle bir soru gündeme geliyor.
İyi de,
bunun için benim,
fonksiyonun,
parametrelerinden,
her birine,
erişmem gerekiyor.
O erişimin hızlı yapacağım.
Arkadaşlar,
burada,
böyle kötü habere söyleyeyim,
dil size doğrudan,
bir araç vermiyor.
Yani şöyle bir şey beklemeyin,
bir döngü oluştururum,
o döngüyle,
bütün parametreleri alırım.
Hayır.
Arkadaşlar,
birden fazla teknik var.
Gelin şimdi,
önce tekniklere,
şöyle kendimiz isimler verelim.
Kullanılan tekniklerden biri,
ben şu terimi yakıştırıyorum,
compile time,
recursive,
pack expansion.
Compile time,
önerili isteği bir tamamlayalım.
Arkadaşlar,
ikinci şansımız,
bu biraz enteresan gelebilir.
Arkadaşlar,
bir,
initializer liste oluşturmak.
Ne alakası var diyeceksiniz.
Anlatacağım.
Ve üçüncüsü,
arkadaşlar,
C++'a,
görece olarak,
daha geç,
eklenen,
hold expressions.
katlama ifadeleri.
Yani,
bir şekilde,
parametreleri kullanmak istiyorsanız,
ya da dördüncüsü,
arkadaşlar,
constexpr'i.
Ve,
recursive'de.
Compile time recursive'de.
Şimdi,
buralar sizi biraz yoracak.
Baştan söyleyeyim.
Yani,
büyük ihtimalle verilen örnekleri,
herkesin başına geldiği gibi,
birinci de anlamayabileceksiniz.
Nedeni şu,
arkadaşlar,
recursive kodları,
insan zihninin algılaması çok kolay olmuyor.
Biraz egzersiz gerekiyor.
Bu runtime recursive vitesi için de geçerli,
ama compile time recursive vitesi için,
daha da geçerli.
Arkadaşlar,
birinciyle başlayalım.
compile time recursive pack expansion.
Burada,
aslında,
işin yapılması şöyle oluyor.
Buraya dikkat.
Hamlete,
parametre paketinin dışında,
bir template parametresi daha ekliyoruz.
Type name,
örneğin t,
type name ps.
Ve fonksiyona da,
yine parametre paketinin dışında,
bir parametre daha ekliyoruz.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi bu durumda ne oluyor?
Çok dikkatli izleyin.
Örneğin,
ben yukarıdaki print fonksiyonuna,
2,
5.6,
efendim,
Alihan,
link başlık tasasını da dahil etmiş olalım.
ve,
diyelim ki,
stotstring,
name,
Oğuzhan,
böyle bir çağrı yaptığımda,
herkes çok dikkatli izlesin.
Arkadaşlar,
söyleyin bakalım,
fonksiyona gönderdiğim,
birinci argüman,
kime gidecek?
Neço,
birinci argüman,
fonksiyonun birinci parametresine gidecek.
Bu durumda,
ben bu fonksiyona,
3 tane argümanla çağrı yaptığımda,
dikkatli izleyin,
parametre paketinde,
kaç tane parametre olacak?
Cevap,
3 tane parametre olacak.
Öyle değil mi?
Peki,
burada ben herhangi bir şekilde,
yine,
print ismini kullanarak,
bir fonksiyon çağrısını yaparken,
buraya çok dikkatli izleyin,
print çağrısını,
bu şekilde yaparsam,
bu sefer,
parametre paketini,
expand etmiş olurum,
değil mi?
Peki,
fonksiyonun kodu sadece bu kadar demiyorum.
Kilit noktayı anlamanızı istiyorum.
O zaman,
ilk çağrılan print fonksiyonu,
ikinci çağrılan print fonksiyonunu,
bir eksik argümanla çağırmış olacak,
değil mi?
Burayı anladık mı?
Evet.
Bravo.
Alian diyor ki,
her seferinde,
paketten biri ayrılıyor.
Arkadaşlar,
bir şey dikkatinizi çekiyor mu?
Bu durumda,
burada çağrılan print fonksiyonu,
anlayacaksınız,
çağrı hiç merak etmeyin.
Burada çağrılan print fonksiyonu,
buraya dikkat.
Aynı print fonksiyonu değil,
öyle değil mi?
Çünkü her defasında,
buradaki print çağrısında,
bir argüman eksilecek.
dolayısıyla,
burada compile time'daki recursive t'yi,
durduracak,
bir mekanizmaya ihtiyacımız var.
Bunun için,
farklı teknikler kullanılabilir.
Ama en çok kullanılan teknik,
bir parametre için,
ayrı bir fonksiyon yazmak,
ve print fonksiyonu,
örneğin,
tek parametre ile çağrıldığında,
artık,
bizim,
parametre paketine sahip,
template'ten değil de,
template,
başka bir template'ten,
ya da başka bir fonksiyondan,
kodun oluşturulması.
Çağrı,
şimdi anlayacaksınız.
Bakın şimdi,
başlangıçta da uyardım,
tabii ki,
anlamak çok kolay olmayabilir.
Ama,
bir kere işin içine girdiğimizde,
artık,
gerisi,
çok kolay olacak.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi bakınız,
buradaki print fonksiyon şablonuna bakın,
ve yukarıdaki print template'ine bakın.
Şimdi soruma cevap vermeye çalışın.
15. satırda yapılan print çağrısı,
bu template'e mi ilişkin,
yukarıdaki template'e mi ilişkin?
Cevap yukarıdaki çağrı,
bravo.
O zaman,
ben 25. satırda print fonksiyonunu çağırdığımda,
birden fazla argüman gönderdiğime göre,
buradan bir fonksiyon yazılacak değil mi?
Buradan yazılacak fonksiyonda,
x,
fonksiyonun birinci parametresine gidecek,
d,
long ve necati string literali,
fonksiyonun parametre paketine gidecek.
Dolayısıyla,
derleyicinin yazdığı fonksiyonun da,
burada çağrılan,
aslında yukarıdaki fonksiyon,
ilk argümanı yazdıracak,
ve burada da pack expansion olduğunda,
bu sefer de pack expansion'da,
aslında,
şu üç değeri olacak.
Öyle değil mi?
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
anlaşıldı mı?
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Bu durumda çağrılan print fonksiyonu da,
yine gönderilen ilk argümanı,
birinci parametre alacak,
ama diğer argümanları bu olacak.
Ne zaman ki,
buraya dikkat,
arkadaşlar,
ne zaman ki,
burada,
pakette,
bir tane,
argüman kaldı,
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Onu da,
en son çağrılan,
print fonksiyonu yazdıracak.
Çünkü,
parametre paketini,
patlattığımız zaman,
bir tane sadece,
print fonksiyonu,
bir parametre ile,
print fonksiyonunu çağırmış olacağız.
O da,
buradaki fonksiyonu çağıracak.
Şimdi,
başlangıçta zor olabilir.
Önce,
gerçekten,
çalışmasına bakalım.
Ama şimdi,
eğer kafanızda,
kurulayamadıysanız,
ben size bir şey göstereyim.
Bakın bakın,
çok dikkatli izleyin.
Şimdi ben,
print fonksiyonu şablonu içinde,
en sonunda,
iki kere üstteki print'e çağrı oluyor.
Bravo.
Arkadaşlar,
bakınız,
print fonksiyonu şablonu içinde,
stut,
see out,
underscore,
punk,
signature,
new line.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
ve,
yukarıdaki print fonksiyonunun,
içindeki yazdırmayı da iptal ediyorum.
Buraya kadar anlaşıldı mı?
Bakın şimdi,
derliyorum,
çalıştırıyorum,
arkadaşlar,
ve,
ekran çıktısına,
bir bakmanızı istiyorum.
Bakın,
ilk çağrılan,
printte,
dört tane template argümanı var.
Birincisi,
birinci template parametresine gitti.
Diğer üçü,
parametre paketine gitti.
Fakat,
ikinci kez çağrılan print fonksiyonu,
aynı print fonksiyonu değil.
Bu sefer,
üç tane template parametresi var.
Birinci,
birinci template parametresine gitti.
Diğer ikisi pakete gitti.
Ve son kez çağrıldığında,
Alihan'ın,
saplamasının doğru olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Bakın,
iki tane template argümanı var.
Biri long,
arkadaşlar,
biri,
yedi elemanlı,
çar dizi.
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Ve,
en son çağrı,
print fonksiyonunda böyle yapıldı ya,
o zaman,
buradaki,
kime gidecek?
Arkadaşlar,
yukarıdaki printe,
parametre paketinde,
bir tane olacak.
Bir tane olduğu için,
açıldığında,
sadece ve sadece bir tane olduğu için,
bu da buna gidecek.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Ama bu kurguyu,
bu recursive kurguyu,
farklı şekillerde de yapabilirdim.
Şimdi başka bir örnek.
İzleyin.
Genel mantık aynı.
Abdülkadir anlaşıldı ama,
şöyle söyleyelim,
biraz belki,
alıştırma yapmak,
iyi fikir olabilir.
Arkadaşlar,
bu sefer,
değiştirdim.
Bakın,
bakın,
bu örnek daha da güzel.
Hatta,
hepsini sileyim.
Şimdi bakın,
bu daha da şık.
herkes dikkatli izliyor.
Fonksiyonu bu şekilde çağırdığım zaman,
yine ilk yapılan çağrı,
bu template'e ilişkin.
Ne zamanki,
print fonksiyonu,
iki parametre ile çağrılacak,
o zaman yukarıdaki template kullanılacak.
Arkadaşlar,
print ilk önce ne yapıyor?
ikinci parametreyi yazdırıyor ve bir virgül koyuyor.
Ondan sonra,
ne yapıyor?
Yine print fonksiyon şablonunda bir çağrı yapıyor.
Orada pack expansion kullanılmış.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Böylece argümanlar sırayla yazdırılıyor.
Fakat,
ne zaman ki,
parametre paketinde,
sadece bir tane parametre kalacak,
bu durumda,
parametre paketi,
ekspant edildiğinde,
burada tek bir argüman olduğu için,
bu sefer yine,
yukarıdaki fonksiyondan yazılmış olacak.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Öyle ya da böyle,
bir neye ihtiyacımız var?
Arkadaşlar,
eksilte,
eksilte bir yerde,
recursivity'yi durdurmamız gerekiyor.
Mesela bakın,
çok şık,
birkaç örnek daha.
Bazıları biraz daha karmaşık olabilir.
Bu örneğe bakın.
Aslında buradaki fonksiyon,
kendisine gönderilen argümanların,
en büyüğünü hesaplamaya yönelik.
Yani bu şekilde çağırdığımda,
en büyük değer olan dördü,
bu şekilde çağırdığımda,
en büyük değer olan 5.1'i döndürüyor.
Doğru çalışıyor inşallah.
Bir argüman daha ekleyelim.
8.2.
Şimdi 8.2 döndürmesi gerekiyor.
Arkadaşlar,
yine max isimli iki tane template var.
fonksiyonun,
iki tane çağrılan fonksiyonun,
iki tane parametresi olduğunda,
bu template kullanılacak.
İkiden fazla parametresi olduğunda,
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
ne zaman ki,
şuradaki max çağrısı,
arkadaşlar,
parametre paketinde,
iki tane argüman,
kaldığında,
ekspant edildi,
o zaman,
dışarıdaki max çağrısı,
o da iki argümanla,
çağrılmış olacak.
o da,
yine yukarıdaki template'ten,
onların,
büyük olanını,
döndürecek.
Mesela,
bu da çok güzel.
İzleyin şimdi,
hoşunuza gidecek bir başka örnek.
Ama hepsi bunların,
sonuçta aynı tekniği kullanıyor.
Bu da çok klasik bir örnek.
Bakın şimdi,
bu sefer,
amaç,
argümanları toplamak.
Yani,
summer isimli fonksiyon,
yaz anlamında değil,
toplayıcı anlamında.
Kaç tane argüman gönderirsem,
onların toplam değerini,
döndürüyor.
Ama tabii ki,
bu,
fonksiyon şablonu olduğu için,
parametreler,
her defasında,
aynı türden olmak zorunda değil.
Mesela,
stringler de toplanır.
Stringle c string toplanır.
Tam sayılar toplanır.
Arkadaşlar,
bakınız,
fonksiyonun,
kodu,
bu,
daha da kolay anlaşılır.
açılabilir.
Aslında,
bir return ifadesinden oluşuyor.
İlk parametre artı,
summer'a yapılan bir çağrı daha.
Pack expansion.
dolayısıyla,
dolayısıyla yine,
summer'ı ilk kez çağrıldığında,
pakette dört tane argüman var.
İkincide üç tane argüman var.
İki tane argüman var.
Buraya dikkat,
bir tane argüman var.
Ne zamanki bir tane argüman var,
o zaman,
bu template'ten kod üretilmek yerine,
yukarıdaki template'ten kod üretilecek değil mi?
Herkes burayı anladı mı?
Yukarıdaki template'te aldığı argümanı döndürdüğüne göre,
o zaman pakette bir tane argüman kaldığında,
summer'ın geri dönüş değeri,
yukarıdaki fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri,
yani argümanın kendisi.
Burada da durdurucu mekanizma olarak,
base case olarak,
bu template'in kullanıldığını görüyorsunuz.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Şimdi bu birinci teknik.
Örnekleri çoğaltmak mümkün.
STL'e geldiğimizde,
daha güzel örnekler de vereceğim.
Yani bu tekniklerin,
hepsinin ortak özelliği,
eksiltme.
Ben eksiltme diyorum.
Yani aynı parametre paketine sahip fonksiyon şablonundan,
her defasında bir fonksiyon çağrısı oluşturmak,
ayrı bir imzaya sahip,
ama parametre paketinden,
Alihan'ın dediği gibi,
argümanları birer birer azaltmak,
ve sonunda da bir base case oluşturmak.
Ama ilginç bir ikinci teknik daha var.
Burayı çok dikkatli izleyelim.
Şimdi burası kafa karıştırışa.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi C kursuna katılmayan,
epey bir arkadaşım var.
Ama katılanlar da var.
Ama kursa katılmadan da çok iyi C'yi öğrenenler de var.
Söyleyin,
C'nin en çok aşağılanan,
fakir görülen,
operatörü hangisi?
Bana bu soru sorulsaydı,
derdim ki,
comma operator,
go to operatör değil,
go to bir kontrol deyimi.
Comma operator,
yani Türkçesiyle virgül operatörü.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi C++'a gelenler,
C'den virgül operatörünü,
iyi öğrenmemiş oluyorlar.
O yüzden ben virgül operatörünü,
önce 3 dakika özetleyeceğim.
5 dakika değil,
3 dakika.
geçersen 3 dakikayı,
ceza yiyeceksin diyeceğim.
Tamam.
Arkadaşlar,
virgül operatörü,
bir operatör.
Yani örneğin,
eğer,
comma separated list değilse,
çünkü her virgül operatör değil,
virgül operatörü,
nasıl toplama bir operatörse,
çarpma bir operatörse,
virgül operatör,
operatörü de bir operatör.
gelin önce virgül operatörünü,
çok kısa konuşalım.
Arkadaşlar,
izleyin,
virgül operatörü,
binary bir operatör.
Binary infix bir operatör.
Bu,
sol operandı,
bu da sağ operandı.
Bakın,
bakın,
mesela,
burada,
x ve y değişkenleri olmak üzere,
x virgül y,
x virgül operatörünün sol operandı,
y sağ operandı.
Virgül operatörünün,
bize ilgilendiren,
iki tane önemli özelliği var.
Birincisi,
virgül operatörünün,
sequence pointı oluşturması.
Bu ne demek?
Örneğin,
üç tane ifade eden,
üç tane deyim yazmak yerine,
sabırlı bir şekilde dinleyin izleme,
mesela,
şöyle yazmak yerine,
artı artı x,
artı artı y,
artı artı z,
bunları,
virgül operatörünün,
operandı olan,
ifadeler yaparsam,
üç ifade yerine,
bin ifade oluşturmuş oluyorum.
Ama,
virgül operatörü bana şu garanti veriyor,
arkadaşlar,
bir sequence point var.
Sequence point olması ne demek?
Önce bu yapılacak,
bunun yan etkisi tamamlandıktan sonra,
bu yapılacak,
bu yapılacak.
Yani ne demek?
Örneğin,
virgül operatörünün operandıları,
şöyle olsaydı,
arkadaşlar,
herhangi bir şekilde anlam yüklemeyin.
Önce hangi işlem yapılacak?
x arttırıldı.
Tıpkı ayrı bir değinmiş gibi.
Peki,
buraya geldiğimizde,
x'in değeri,
x'in artık artmış değeri olma garantisi var mı?
Cevap,
kesinlikle.
Yani artık burada,
x değişkenlerinin değeri 11,
10 değil.
Tıpkı ayrı bir değinmiş gibi.
Dolayısıyla,
sequence point oluşturması,
bu operatörün,
evaluate edilmesinden sonraki,
yan etkilerin,
daha sağdaki operand,
ele alındığında,
artık etkisini göstermiş olması demek.
Bu çok çok önemli.
Burayı bir kere anladınız mı?
C'de bu konuyu öğrenmeyen arkadaşlar,
burayı anladınız mı?
Mesela bakınız,
başka bir örnek.
İzir.
Primtef,
Ali,
virgül,
printf,
Veli.
Virgül operatörünün sağ operandı,
sol operandı ve sağ operandı.
Önce bu printf çağrısının,
sonra bu printf çağrısının yapılması garanti altında mı?
Evet ya da hayır diyeyim.
Cevap,
evet kesinlikle.
Yani örneğin,
önce standart alt kuta belli,
sonra Ali yazması gibi bir ihtimal söz konusu mu?
Asla.
Takip edebiliyor musunuz?
Evet.
Birinci önemli özellik,
virgül operatörünün bir sequence point oluşturması.
Bundan faydalanacağız birazdan.
İki,
arkadaşlar,
virgül operatörü de diğer operatörler gibi bir değer üretiyor.
Virgül operatörünün ürettiği değer,
sağ operandın değeri.
yani,
x virgül y ifadesinin değeri ne?
Bu ifadenin türü ve değeri ne?
Cevap,
türü int,
değeri 20.
Mesela,
benim üçüncü bir değişkenim daha olsa,
buraya özellikle dikkat.
ve ben
böyle bir deyim oluştursam,
niye böyle bir deyim oluşturduğumda uğraşmayın lütfen.
z'ye kaç atılacak?
Cevap,
söyleyin,
20,
y'nin değeri.
Gerçekten de,
bakınız arkadaşlar,
z'nin değerini yazdıracağım.
ve z'nin değerinin
20 olduğunu göreceksiniz.
Peki,
şimdi aynı z'ye bir atama daha yapalım.
Ve bu sefer,
y virgül x diyelim.
Bu sefer de bu ifadenin değeri
10 arkadaşlar.
Hakim edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Hayır,
uneverlated konteks değil kesinlikle.
Hepsine cevap vereceğim,
merak etmeyin.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi bir iki noktaya daha
dikkat çekelim.
Bakın,
burada öncelik parantezi
olmasaydı,
virgül operatörünün önceliği
atama operatöründen
bile düşük.
Dolayısıyla bu durumda,
arkadaşlar,
virgül operatörünün
sol operandı z'ye eşittir.
x sağ operandı y.
Dolayısıyla ben,
x virgül y ifadesinin
değerinin
atama operatörünün
sağ operandı olması için
ne yapmak zorundayım?
Öncelik parantezi
kullanmak zorundayım.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Dünkü arkadaşım,
ben soruyu doğru anladıysam,
şöyle bir ifade
oluştursaydım,
bu ifadede
A,
herhangi bir şekilde
bir tanımsız davranış var mı?
Cevap,
hayır.
B,
x artacak mı?
Cevap,
evet.
Virgül operatörünün
sol operandı da,
sağ operandı da
evaluate ediliyor.
Zaten,
ondan faydalanacağız birazdan.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
mesela,
bakın,
bu C'de o kadar şık
hileler var ki
virgül operatörüyle ilgili.
Mesela bakınız,
printf,
alican,
arkadaşlar.
Soru,
z,
y'nin değeri atanacak
ama
standart output'a da
alican yazacak mı?
Cevap,
evet.
Unavaluated context olsaydı,
alican yazma garantisi
olmazdı.
Takip edebildik mi?
Evet.
Şimdi yavaş yavaş
konuya gireceğiz.
Peki,
soru
arkadaşlar.
İzleyin.
Ben şöyle bir kod yazsam.
Mesela,
see out
using
varmış,
evet.
see out
x
arkadaşlar,
virgül
sıfır.
Şimdi,
bu bir ifade mi?
Evet.
bu bir ifade olduğuna göre,
virgül operatörünün sol operandı değil mi?
Çünkü virgül operatörü daha düşük önceliğe sahip.
Dolayısıyla,
tıpkı az önceki printf çağrısında olduğu gibi,
burada,
virgül operatörünün sol operandının evaluate edilmesi demek,
bu işlemin,
bu deyimin,
bu ifadenin yürütülmesi demek.
yani bu durumda,
ben örneğin,
böyle bir ifade yazarsam,
arkadaşlar,
virgül operatörünün sol operandı bu ifade,
sağ operandı bu ifade olur değil mi?
Burayı kaçırmamanız gerekiyor.
Evet.
O zaman,
standart output örneğin 10 yazar mı?
Cevap evet.
Ama şimdi,
ikinci soruya cevap vermeye çalışın.
İkinci soru.
Peki,
bu ifadenin değeri ne?
Cevap,
sıfır.
Peki,
şimdi çok dikkatli izleyin.
Diyelim ki,
benim şöyle değişkenlerim olsa,
nereden nereye geleceğiz?
Çok şaşıracaksınız.
Benim böyle değişkenlerim olsa,
ben arkadaşlar,
bunları örneğin parantez içine alsam
ve bunları da virgül operatörünün operandı yapsam.
Hatta,
şöyle boşluk da olsun.
Tamam.
Bakın,
buradaki virgül operatör.
Ama şimdi dikkat edin.
Eğer,
benim bir dizim olsaydı,
bu diziyi,
initialize etseydim,
arkadaşlar,
Sadece soruya cevap vermeye çalışın.
Soru,
A dizisinin kaç elemanı var?
Cevap,
3.
buradaki virgül operatör mü?
Evet ya da hayır.
Peki,
buradaki virgül operatör mü?
Cevap,
hayır.
Buradaki virgül operatör değil,
buradaki virgül,
comma separated listin virgülü.
Ama şimdi soruya cevap vermeye çalışın.
Peki,
virgül operatörü sequence point oluşturduğuna göre,
bu ifadenin yürütülmesi demek,
önce bu ifadenin yürütülmesi demek değil mi?
Sol operandan önce yürütülme garantisi vardı ya,
o zaman bu diziye bu şekilde ilk değer verdiğimde,
x'in, y'nin ve z'nin de değerleri,
standart output'a yazdırılır desem katılır mısınız?
Cevap,
evet.
Evet.
Bakın.
Şimdi o zaman,
gelelim,
variadic parametre paketinde bunu nasıl kullanacağımıza.
Arkadaşlar,
şöyle bir parametre paketi olsa,
template parametre paketi olsa,
void,
print.
const,
ts,
ref,
arcs.
Şimdi çok şaşıracaksınız.
Az önce yaptığımı buraya yazıyorum.
Stociao,
arkadaşlar,
izleyin.
arcs,
virgül sıfır,
pack expansion.
Bunu nasıl bir virgüllerle ayrılmış listeye dönüştürecek?
Hatta şuraya bir de boşluk verelim.
Bunu nasıl bir virgüllerle ayrılmış listeye,
arkadaşlar,
ayıracak?
bir,
bunu yazacak,
burada fonksiyonun birinci parametresi olacak.
Buradaki virgülü operatör virgül,
comma separated liste dönüştürüyordu ya,
o zaman,
bütün parametreler bu şekilde sırasıyla,
comma separated listin,
böyle ileri olacak.
İsterseniz gösterelim.
Bakın,
sıkılmayacaksınız.
Şöyle değil mi?
Şuna aldım.
Fonksiyonun parametreleri P1, P2, P3 olsun.
Aslında burada P1 var.
Arkadaşlar,
burada yine aynı ifade,
ama P2 var.
Yine aynı ifade,
burada P3 var.
Şimdi söyleyin,
virgüllerle ayrılmış bir liste olarak bunu kullanırsam,
örneğin,
bir diziye ilk değer verirsem,
ki daha iyisini yapacağım,
sadece soruma cevap vermeye çalışıyorum.
O zaman burada bir küve parantezi olması lazım.
Burada da küve parantezinin kapanması lazım.
Buraya kadar yakaladınız mı?
Şimdi söyler misiniz,
parametre paketinde 5 tane parametre varsa,
aslında ben 5 elemanlı bir diziye ilk değer vermiş olurum,
değil mi?
Aslında dizinin bütün elemanlarına,
sıfır değerini vermiş olurum.
Ama burada sequence point oluşturduğu için,
sırasıyla argümanların hepsini yazacak.
Ama diyeceksiniz ki,
Necati bu güzel ama,
sen bir dizi tanımlamış olacaksın,
onu da açmanın yolu var,
merak etmeyin.
Ama önce,
mesela böyle bırakmayı sevmem tabii,
olmaz, çok çirkin olur.
Bir kere en iyi ihtimalle,
herhangi bir derleyici burada,
bu dizi kullanılmadığı için,
uyarı mesajı verebilir,
sentaks hatası olmasa da.
İzleyin şimdi,
gerçekten bir deneyelim,
print fonksiyonuna çağrı yapalım,
ve,
hatta argümanların türüne bakın,
2,
2.3,
efendim,
Alihan,
ve,
mesela,
bitset başlık dosyasında,
inkulu dediğim,
ve,
stud bitset'in,
16 açılımı türünden,
bu sınıfı henüz öğrenmedik,
453u.
ve bakın şimdi,
derliyorum,
bir sentaks hatası yok,
çalıştırıyorum,
gayet de güzel,
argümanları yazdırdı,
2,
2.3,
Alihan,
şimdi bundan daha iyisini yapabiliriz,
çünkü,
burada kullanılmayan bir ne var,
arkadaşlar,
dizi var,
ya bunu,
initializer list yapabiliriz,
arkadaşlar,
bakın,
initializer listin,
tut,
arkadaşlar,
int açılımı,
ki,
aslında,
burada,
yine,
sitatla,
template argümanını yazmak zorunda da değilim,
yani,
şöyle yazmakla,
deduction'a bırakmak,
arasında bir fark yok,
bravo,
cenzan ve,
ve,
bu,
artık bir,
PR value,
ama,
ee,
ifadeyi de,
void türüne test edersem,
herhangi bir şekilde,
uyarı alma ihtimalim de,
ortadan,
kalkacak,
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet,
aynı işi,
yine böyle yapmış olacağım,
arkadaşlar,
tabi bu tekniğin,
türevleri var,
farklı şekilde yazabilirim,
ama,
ortak özellik,
aslında,
virgül operatörünün,
sequence point oluşturması,
ve virgül operatörünün,
ürettiği değerin,
sağ operandın,
değeri olmasından,
kaynaklanıyor,
anlaşıldı mı?
Evet,
peki,
bu da,
bizim,
ikinci,
tekniğimiz,
diyebiliriz,
başka teknikler var mı?
Evet,
arkadaşlar,
üçüncü teknik,
buraya dikkat,
neden faydalanmak?
Compile time if'den,
faydalanmak,
yine rekürsif yapı,
ama,
bu sefer,
kullanacağım,
araç,
henüz bizim görmediğimiz,
şimdi birazdan,
o konuya da gireceğim,
compile time if,
o zaman hemen,
C++ 17 standardıyla,
dilimize eklenen,
en önemli araçlardan biri olan,
neyi görmeye başlayalım?
if,
constexpr,
constexpr if,
compile time if,
static if,
farklı farklı işler,
farklı terim kullanabiliyorlar,
ama sonuçta,
hepsi,
aynı,
konuya,
işaret ediyor.
Arkadaşlar,
izleyin,
şuraya da,
hazırlatayım örnekleri açtım.
Bakın şimdi,
yine dilin,
en önemli araçlarından biriyle tanışacağız.
Yani,
şimdiye kadar,
hiç bundan bahsetmemiş olabiliriz,
ya da çok az bahsetmiş olabiliriz,
ama,
C++,
görece olarak,
dilin de gerçeklenmiş olsa,
dilin en önemli araçlarından biri.
Arkadaşlar,
biz,
C dilinde,
ön işlemci programın,
conditional compiling komutlarını kullanarak,
derleyicinin bir kodu görmesini,
ya da bir kodu görmemesini,
yani compile time'da derleyici için kod seçimini yaptırabiliyorduk.
Ben C kursunda,
conditional compiling başlığı altında,
hem burada kullanılan ön işlemci komutlarını,
hem de buradaki yapıyı,
detaylı bir şekilde anlattım.
fakat şimdi,
C++ 17 itibariyle,
derleyicinin bir kodu görmesi,
ya da görmemesini sağlayacak,
ön işlemci programı,
hiç devreye katmadan,
bir,
derleme zamanında,
ele alınacak if deyim var.
Ne demek bir if deyiminin,
derleme zamanında ele alınması?
Burada amaç,
if'in,
kontrol ifadesi,
yani conditional expression'ı,
bir constant expression olacak.
Eğer o constant expression,
compile time'da,
true değer üretirse,
o zaman,
derleyici,
if'in doğru kısmındaki kodu derleyecek.
eğer false değer üretirse,
if'in yanlış kısmı varsa,
yanlış kısmındaki kodu derleyecek.
Arkadaşlar,
yanlış kısmı yoksa,
herhangi bir kodu derlemeyecek.
Dolayısıyla,
jenerik bir koda,
mesela bakın,
template type name'de,
void,
func,
p.
Biraz kodun jenerik olması burada,
son derece önemli.
yani,
fonksiyon şablonu söz konusu.
Necati fonksiyon şablonu,
yoksa normal fonksiyonun içinde de,
statik if'i kullanamaz mıyız?
Kullanırız ama orada,
bazı kurallar farklı.
Şimdi bakın,
önce,
deyim nasıl oluşturuluyor?
if'ten sonra,
constant expression anahtar sözcüğü var.
Yani bakınız,
şu if deyimi,
bizim bildiğimiz,
runtime'a yönelik if deyimi,
hayır hayır,
si'deki if defle,
hiçbir alakası yok kabe.
si'deki if def,
preprocesör programını kullanıyor.
Bunun preprocesörle,
uzaktan yakından bir alakası yok.
Sadece ve sadece,
compiler devrede.
Yani ön işlemci,
biz Türkçe'de ön işlemci program diyoruz.
Onun yaptığı işi,
yapar mı anlamında söylüyorsanız,
ondan çok daha fazlasına muktedir.
kadir.
Yani,
koşullu derleme if defle yapabileceğimiz şeylerin,
çok daha fazlasını yapma şansına sahibiz.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın şimdi,
burada,
herhangi bir constant expression olabilir.
Örneğin,
true.
örneğin,
arkadaşlar,
12,
boolean olarak yorumlayacak.
Tabii ki,
buradaki constant expression,
template parametresiyle de ilgili olabilir.
Mesela,
if size of t,
büyük,
2.
Sadece,
kodu anlamaya çalışın.
Ben bu fonksiyona,
örneğin,
argüman olarak,
arkadaşlar,
short türden bir değişkenin ifade olarak versem.
Bu durumda,
didaction'da template parametresi short olacak değil mi?
Evet.
Peki,
burada statik if varsa,
compile time'da sınanan bu ifade,
benim derleyicim için doğru mu yanlış mı?
Benim derleyicimde short türü 2 byte.
yanlış.
O zaman,
if'in içindeki bu kodu,
mesela burada herhangi bir kodu olabilir.
Arkadaşlar,
Iostream sadece göstermek için,
see up,
derlenen kod,
compiled kod,
is
through path.
Through path.
as
olmayan da bilirdi.
compiled kod,
is
possible.
Şimdi önce,
ne anlama geldiğini iyi anlamamız gerekiyor.
Soru 1,
derleyici bu fonksiyon şablondan bir fonksiyon kodu yazacak değil mi?
Evet.
Peki,
derleyicinin yazacağı kod,
ya bu deyimden oluşacak,
ya da bu deyimden oluşacak.
Hakip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Peki,
bu örnek için derleyicinin yazdığı kod,
parametresi short olan bir fonksiyon,
fakat fonksiyonun içinde sadece böyle bir deyim var.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Derleyici bu kodu derlemiyor,
bu koda yok muamelesi yapıyor.
Sadece bu kodu derliyor.
Eğer,
örneğin,
fonksiyona,
intürden bir argüman gönderseydim,
hatta deneyelim bakın,
önce fonksiyonu,
s ile çağırıyorum,
ondan sonra da intürden bir değerle çağırıyorum.
Fonksiyonu s ile çağırdığım zaman,
runtime'da değil,
compile time'da derleyici bu kodu oluyor.
fonksiyonu 45 ile çağırdığımda,
arkadaşlar,
bu sefer de ifin doğru kısmındaki kodu oluyor.
Şimdi diğer çağrıya bakın.
Ooo,
çok da önemli bir araç.
Şimdi burada,
bir,
arkadaşlar,
bu ifadenin constant expression olma mecburiyeti var.
yani mesela burada şöyle bir kod yazabilir misiniz?
T türünden x,
efendim,
x büyük 10.
Hayır,
bu sabit ifadesi olmaz.
Buradaki ifade,
sabit ifadesi olacak.
Bu bir.
İkincisi,
şimdi sıkı durun.
Arkadaşlar,
derleyicinin derlemediği kısımdaki kod,
sentax hatası oluşturmayacak.
Mesela,
izleyin,
şöyle bir kodu olsaydı,
struct,
nec,
arkadaşlar,
izleyin,
void,
foo.
Şimdi,
nec'in foo isimli bir üye fonksiyonu var değil mi?
Kesinlikle.
Peki,
ben burada,
şöyle bir çağrı yapsam,
x'in foo'su.
Arkadaşlar,
izleyin.
Ve,
bu fonksiyona,
bu sefer koşul ifadesi başka bir compile time ifadesi olsa,
mesela,
high trades kütüphanesindeki,
meta function'lardan birini kullansam,
geçen derslerden birinde bahsetmiştik.
Mesela,
buradaki ifade şöyle olsa,
iz,
arkadaşlar,
efendim,
tut,
iz,
integral,
underscore v'nin,
p açılımı.
Şimdi,
bu ifadenin doğru olması için,
t türünün tam sayı türlerinden biri olması gerekiyor,
değil mi?
evet,
o zaman,
şimdi de tam sayı türlerinden biri olmaması gerekiyor,
değil mi?
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Şimdi söyleyin bakalım,
ben bu fonksiyona,
çağrı yaparken,
arkadaşlar,
pan fonksiyonunu,
efendim,
12 değeriyle çağırsam,
bu durumda t türü int olacak,
burası,
fos olacak,
ve derleyici bu kodu üretecek.
eğer,
bu kodu da derleseydi,
int türden değişkeni,
nokta operatörünün operanda yapmış olacaktım,
değil mi,
Kave?
Bu da sentaks hatası oluşturacaktı,
değil mi?
Ama şimdi sentaks hatası oluşacak mı?
Hayır.
Çünkü derleyici bu kodu derlemiyor.
Derleyici bu kodu derlemediği için,
sentaks hatası da oluşmayacak.
En önemli özelliklerinden biri,
bu.
anlaşıldı mı?
Yani derlenmeyen kısımda,
name lookup'la ilgili bir problem olmadığı sürece,
isim aramayla ilgili,
o kod derlenmiyor.
O kodun sentaksa uygun olması gerekmiyor.
Böylece,
bu aracı kullanarak,
yani compile time if'i kullanarak,
normalde overloading ile yapabileceğim,
bir yazabileceğim bir sürü kodu,
tik bir fonksiyon şablonuyla,
yazma şansına sahip oluyor.
Müthiş bir araç aslına bakarsanız.
Hadi gelin birkaç örnek verelim.
Ama arkadaşlar,
çok sık yapılan bir hatayı,
hemen söyleyerek başlayalım.
Şimdi,
nasıl sadece doğru kısmı olan if deyimi var,
sadece doğru olan,
statik if deyimi de var.
Hem doğru,
hem yanlış kısmı olan,
hem true pet'e sahip,
hem false pet'e sahip,
bir if deyimi var,
onun statik if versiyonu da var.
Bir de else if merdiveni var,
değil mi?
İşte çok yapılan hatalardan biri,
else if merdivenini compile time'de oluştururken,
arkadaşlar,
constex pr'yi yazmamak.
Eğer constex pr'yi burada yazmazsanız,
bu artık ne olmayacak?
Statik if olmayacak,
normal if deyimi olacak,
compile time değeri alınacak.
Yani,
else if constex pr'yi yazmakla,
else if yazmak tamamen farklı şeyler.
Else if yazarsam,
bir kere bir kod seçimi söz konusu değil,
bu da oradan kodun bir parçası.
Anlaşıldı, değil mi?
Ayrıca,
else if yazarsam,
buradaki ifadenin constant expression olması da gerekmiyor.
Yani örneğin,
yanlışlıkla else if yazsanız,
ve buradaki ifade constant expression değilse,
sentaks hatası olmaz.
Dolayısıyla,
compile time'da bir branching sağlamak için,
bir dallanma,
branching sağlamak için,
muhtemelen yazmak istediğiniz,
diğer branch'lerin de,
yine ne olması?
else if constex pr olması.
Buraya kadar her şey anlaşıldı mı?
Çok sayıda örnek yapacağız.
Ama isterseniz önce bir ara verelim.
saat 21.08 arkadaşlar,
21.25'te devam edeceğiz.
Evet,
21.25'te devam ediyoruz.
Arkadaşlar,
mesela böylece,
template parametresi ya da parametrelerinin,
türlerinin ne olduğuna bağlı olarak,
ya da,
template parametresinin,
niteliklerinin ne olduğuna bağlı olarak,
farklı kodların değerlenmesini sağlayabilirsiniz.
Yani bu durumda,
specialization mekanizmasını oluşturmak,
ya da template,
fonksiyon şablonlarını,
overload etmek yerine,
tek bir fonksiyon şablonuyla,
dilediğinizi yapabilirsiniz.
Mesela aslında buradaki örnek,
onu da çağrıştırıyor değil mi?
Burada bir,
else kısmı olsaydı,
burada kodların ne olduğundan,
bağımsız olarak,
aslında biz şöyle bir kod oluşturmuş olurduk değil mi?
Şuradaki lojik değil operatörünü de kaldıralım.
Eğer t türü,
tam sayı türü ise,
buradaki kod derlensin.
Tam sayı türü değilse,
Ya da,
diğer,
daha önce öğrendiğimiz,
en azından gördüğümüz,
metafarkçılara bakın,
elsir,
constexpr,
arkadaşlar,
efendim,
stut,
is,
floating point,
ve,
else,
şimdi buralarda kodlar olduğunu düşünün.
Eğer,
ham sayı türü ise,
if'in doğru kısmına girecek.
Burada,
if'in doğru kısmına,
compile time'da girmesinden bahsediyoruz.
Yani buradaki kod derlenecek.
eğer,
tabi şunu yazmayı unutmuşuz,
açısal parantezde,
eğer t türü,
floating point türü ise,
yani gerçek sayı türlerinden biriyse,
burada bir kod.
Ham sayı türü ya da gerçek sayı türü değilse,
o zaman buradaki kod çalışacak.
Ya da örneğin,
t türü'nün,
pointer türü olup olmadığına,
referans türü olup olmadığına,
dizi türü olup olmadığına bağlı olarak,
farklı kodların derlenmesini sağlayabilirsiniz.
Şimdi,
benim daha önce yazdığım,
kitaba da koyduğum örneklerden,
önce,
genel sentaksı pekiştirecek,
ve efendim,
kullanım biçimini pekiştirecek,
bir iki örnek verelim.
Yani biraz,
üretime yakın örnekler olsun,
oyuncak örnekler olmanın dışında.
Mesela,
bu gerçekten,
çok hoş bir kod.
İsmi,
as string olan,
bir fonksiyon şablonu görüyorsunuz.
Ve,
fonksiyon şablonunun kodunda,
isSame,
meta function'ın,
type trait'in kullanıldığını görüyorsunuz.
IsSame buradaki,
template argümanı olan türlerin,
aynı tür olup olmadığı,
sınamasını yapıyordu.
Bu da bir,
variable template.
Bu konuları anlattığım için,
tekrar şimdi bahsetmeyeceğim.
Ama şu demek,
eğer buraya gelen tür,
string türü ise,
to string ise,
doğru olacak ve bu kod,
derlenecek.
Eğer buraya gelen tür,
arkadaşlar,
string türü değil de,
aritmetik bir tür ise,
aritmetik tür demek,
tam sayı,
gerçek sayı türleri demek.
mesela double türü,
double türü,
int türü,
long türü,
bunlar aritmetik türler.
O zaman,
standart kütüphanenin,
to string fonksiyonuna,
argüman olarak gönderecek,
to string'in,
geri dönüş değeri,
geri dönüş değerimiz olacak.
eğer aritmetik tür değilse,
buraya dikkat,
string türü de değilse,
o zaman,
bu kod çalışacak,
bu kodun çalışması demek,
argümanın,
kime gönderilmesi demek,
string sınıfının,
constructor'ına gönderilmesi,
ve böylece,
oluşturulacak,
PR value expression ile,
arkadaşlar,
tabi ki,
mandatory copy allegion da,
devreye girecek burada,
geri dönüş değerinin,
oluşturulması demek.
Şimdi düşünün,
eğer,
if constexpr olmasaydı,
aslında biz bunu,
overloading ile,
ya da,
henüz size anlatmadığım,
tag dispatch dediğimiz teknikle,
ya da yine size anlatmadığım,
spina dediğimiz teknikle,
gerçekleştirebilirdik.
Yani başka alternatifler yok değil.
Ama doğrusu isterseniz,
burada en pratiği,
gerçekten,
static if.
Burada bir şeye daha dikkat edelim.
Mesela,
arkadaşlar,
eğer,
t türü,
double türü olsaydı,
string nesnesini,
double türden bir argümanla,
oluşturmak mümkün olur muydu?
Sentax hatası olurdu,
değil mi?
Parametresi,
double olan bir konstruktör var mı,
string sınıfının?
Yok.
Sentax hatası olurdu.
Ve bu durumda,
ya da burada,
belirli türler için,
sentax hatası olurdu.
Ama bu kod derlenmiyor.
O yüzden,
sadece t'nin,
aritmetik türü olması durumunda,
bu kod derlenecek.
sadece t'nin string türü olması durumunda,
Ve şimdi bakın,
alttaki main fonksiyonunda,
yukarıdaki,
as string fonksiyon şablonuna,
int türden,
argümanla çağrı yaptığımda,
arkadaşlar,
bu kod çalışacak.
yani,
aslında bir one-liner gövdeye sahip,
bir fonksiyonu çağırmış oluyorum,
herhalde.
Ama o one-liner gövde,
body,
ya return x,
ya return stut,
to string x,
ya da,
bu.
ikinci çağrıda,
yirmi üçüncü satırdaki çağrıda,
yine double gönderdiğim için,
yine bu kod çalışacak.
Ama üçüncü çağrıda,
gönderilen argüman,
string türünden olduğu için,
birinci,
koşul ifadesi,
compile time'da,
true olacak.
Ve bu kod derlenecek.
Ve en son çağrıya batıp,
gönderdiğim argüman,
constjar yıldız,
referans parametri olmadığı için,
arkadaşlar,
decay olacak.
Bu durumda string değil,
aritmetik tür değil,
buradaki,
return statement,
derlenecek.
Evet,
runtime'a bakın.
Takip edebildik mi?
Evet.
Yalnız arkadaşlar,
ikinci örnekte,
dikkatinizi çekmesi gereken,
bir iki nokta var.
Arkadaşlar,
bir,
buradaki if,
statik if,
ama buradaki if,
statik if değil.
Dolayısıyla,
bu koşul doğruysa,
derleyicinin göreceği kod,
bu if deyimi olacak.
Ama bu koşul yanlışsa,
derleyicinin gördüğü kod,
bu kodu olacak.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Şimdi izleyin.
Eğer,
t türü tam sayı türü ise,
derleyici,
bu kodu görecek değil mi?
bu durumda,
eksi eksi operatörünün örneğin,
operanda olması,
bir sentaks hatası oluşturmayacak.
Ve buradaki çağrı,
rekörsif çağrı olacak.
Eğer t türü,
tam sayı türü değilse,
els kısmı derlenecek.
Ama bir şeye dikkat edin.
Arkadaşlar,
eğer burada,
els tarafında bu kod olsaydı,
bu durumda,
t türünün,
tam sayı türü olsa da,
olmasa da,
sentaks hatası oluşurdu.
Neden?
Çünkü isim arama yine yapılıyor.
Eğer,
template parametresine bağlı değilse,
yani dependent type değilse,
isim araması yapılıyor.
Burada funksiyona bir argüman göndermediğim için,
bu isim,
template kodun derlenmesi sırasında aranıyor.
Yani t,
tam sayı türü olsa da,
olmasa da,
bu ismin aranıp bulunmaması,
sentaks hatası oluşturacak.
Ama,
burada,
template argümanına bağlı isim arandığı için,
undeclared,
sözde,
fonksiyonla,
tx argüman olarak gönderildiği için,
bu ismin aranması için,
arkadaşlar,
else kısmındaki kodun derlenmesi gerekiyor.
Else kısmındaki kod derlenmezse,
burada bir sentaks hatası,
olmayacak.
Alihan,
hocam bunlar,
compile time'da olduğu için,
string ifadesi,
runtime'da değer belirlenen öğelerle çağrı yapmak,
sentaks hatası mıdır?
Tabii ki değildir.
Alihan,
çok önemli bir noktayı kaçırmış olmalısınız.
compile time'da kod seçimi yapılıyor.
Ama çağrılan fonksiyon,
runtime'da çağrılıyor.
Yani örneğin,
fonksiyonu şöyle çağırırsak,
şimdi aradaki farkı,
anlayacağınız bir örnek vereyim.
Mesela bakınız,
int x eşittir,
bu.
Bu da bir fonksiyon olsun.
x'in değeri runtime'da belli oluyor,
değil mi?
Evet.
Peki,
funk'ı böyle çağırmamda bir,
herhangi bir şekilde,
bir sentaks hatası var mı?
Hayır.
Peki,
bu durumda,
funk bir fonksiyon çablonu olduğu için,
derleyici bu fonksiyon çablonundan bir,
instant sharing yapacak,
değil mi?
Derleyicinin yazdığı,
funk fonksiyonu,
şöyle bir fonksiyon olacak.
Çağır Alihan.
Aslında,
void,
funk'ın,
int specialization'ı,
parametresi int,
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Ve,
kodu da,
bu.
Anlaşıldı mı?
yani,
runtime ile ilgisi olan kısım ayrı,
compile time ile ilgisi olan kısım ayrı.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Ve yine,
bir şeye daha bakınız,
az önce söylediğim.
Arkadaşlar,
eğer,
buradaki,
ifade doğruysa,
compile time de doğruysa,
t türü,
tam sayı türüdür.
Ve bu kod,
sentaks hatası oluşturmaz.
Ama örneğin,
ben bu fonksiyona şöyle bir çağrı yapsaydım.
Class,
my class,
izleyin.
Ve fonksiyona,
my class türünden bir argüman gönderseydim.
Yine bakın,
Alihan,
sizin sorunuza başka bir cevap olacak.
My class türünden bir argüman gönderseydim.
Şimdi,
t türü,
integral type olmadığı için,
bu kod derlenmeyecekti.
Bu kod derlenmediği için,
sıfırla karşılaştırma işlemi yapılmayacaktı.
Eksi eksi ifadesi için kod derlenmeyecekti.
Ve sentaks hatası oluşmayacaktı.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Burada örneğin,
gerçekten şöyle bir kod olsaydı,
t x'in,
ne olsun,
bar isimli fonksiyonu çağrılsın.
Artı artı,
p x.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi sentaks hatası olur.
Ama,
bu sınıfın,
gerçekten bu operasyonları olsaydı,
örneğin,
sınıfın çağrılabilen,
bir bar fonksiyonu olsaydı,
efendim,
artı artı operatörünü,
overload etseydi,
bu durumda,
bu da sentaks hatası oluşturmayacaktı.
Gördüğünüz gibi kod,
legal.
anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi bunun,
önemli bir özelliği de,
fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerinin,
türünün,
yine,
compile time'da belirli olması.
mesela şöyle bir kod yazsaydım,
bu fonksiyon şablonu değil de,
arkadaşlar,
constex.tr if değil de,
normal if olsaydı,
bakınız,
void,
void diyorum özür dilerim,
auto,
func,
int x,
efendim,
if x büyüktür on,
return,
4.5,
as,
return,
3.
bu neden sentaks hatası,
çünkü fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri türü,
farklı return statement'larda,
farklı şekilde,
çıkarımı yapılacak.
burada geri dönüş değeri türü double,
burada ise geri dönüş değeri türü int.
Bu da,
sentaks hatası oluşturacak.
Bakın derleyici,
açıkça sentaks hatasının nedenini,
söylüyor.
Ama,
constex.tr if de böyle değil.
Arkadaşlar,
fonksiyon şöyle olsaydı,
izleyin,
if,
constex.tr,
size of,
efendim,
x büyük,
2,
as,
şimdi bakın,
sentaks hatası,
olmayacak.
Yani geri dönüş değeri türünde,
template parametresine bağlı olarak,
ya da normal bir fonksiyonda da kullanırsanız,
bu şekilde farklı tür yapmanız,
mümkün.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Yalnız bir şeye dikkat edin.
Başta da söylemiştim.
Eğer fonksiyon çablonu değilse,
if constex.tr'nin true kısmı da,
false kısmı da,
yani true peti de,
false peti de,
compile time'da,
hata oluşturmayacak kodlardan oluşmalı.
struct,
my class,
my class bir sınıf.
Arkadaşlar,
diyelim ki,
main fonksiyonu içine şöyle bir kod yazabilir miyim?
my class,
me,
if constex.br,
size of int,
parantez olunacak tabi,
büyüktür 2,
artı artı m,
bakın hemen sentax hatası işaretliyor.
Çünkü bu template kod değil.
Yani size of int,
2'den büyük olmasa da,
şimdi onu kapatalım,
else,
diyelim ki,
eksi eksi mi?
Bakın hem doğru kısmında,
hem yanlış kısmında,
yardımcı aracımız,
doğrudan,
sentax hatası işaretliyor.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Şimdi,
tabi bambaşka amaçlar içinde kullanılabilir.
Mesela şöyle bir örnek,
belki biraz kafa karıştırıcı ama,
int,
n,
bunun type parametre,
espriye bakın şimdi,
constexpr,
int,
fibonacci hesaplayacak.
Bu örnek genelde,
insanların çoğunu yanıltıyor.
İzleyin.
constexpr,
fonksiyon kendisi de constexpr,
int,
fibonacci hesaplayacak.
arkadaşlar,
if constexpr,
n büyük eşit,
2,
yani fibonacci fonksiyonunun,
arkadaşlar,
2'den büyük ya da eşit,
specialization'ları söz konusu olduğunda,
burada kod derlenecek.
return,
fibon,
n-1,
artı,
fibon,
n-2,
as,
return,
n-1,
bunu compile-time miti ile karıştırmıyoruz değil mi?
mesela ben,
fibon,
8,
ya da 7,
böyle bir fonksiyonu çağırdığımda,
çağırdığım fonksiyonun return ifadesi bu olacak,
çünkü en büyük eşit 2.
bu durumda,
2 fonksiyon daha yazılacak,
yazılacak fonksiyonlardan biri,
fibonun 6 açılımı,
öbürü fibonun 5 açılımı,
oradan da yine 2 tane fonksiyon yazılacak,
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
evet,
arkadaşlar,
ama,
en son,
fibonun,
şurada fonksiyon çağırı operatörünü koymamışım,
1 ya da 0 açılımı söz konusu olduğunda,
orada çağırılan fonksiyonun kodu,
return n,
yani return 1 ya da 0,
böylece yine,
compile-time'da fonksiyon yazdırarak,
arkadaşlar,
fibonacci sayısını,
fibonacci serisinin eninci terimini,
bu şekilde hesaplatmak mümkün değil,
diyebilirsiniz ki,
böyle bir şeye ne gerek var,
haklısınız,
kaldı ki bakın,
bu da bir sabit ifadesi,
şimdi,
eğer başka bir hata yoksa,
constexpr,
auto,
while,
eşittir,
burada da göstermesi lazım,
bakın,
yedinci terim,
neymiş,
13'miş,
akıllı kadir diyor ki,
lisans döneminde,
sınav sorumuzdu,
mesela bakın,
çok güzel bir örnek daha,
böyle bir fonksiyon yazmak istiyorum ki,
parametresi pointer ise,
geri dönüş değeri,
o pointer'ın gösterdiği nesnenin değeri olsun,
ama parametresi pointer değilse,
parametrenin kendi değeri olsun,
template type name t,
auto,
get value olsun fonksiyonun ismi,
t,
arkadaşlar,
x,
if constexpr,
type trace başlık dosyası,
include edilmiş durumda,
t'nin,
fons evitörü olup olmadığını,
sorgulamak için,
sput,
is,
integral,
ya şöyle yazacağım artık buna alıştık değil mi,
isintegral t'nin value'su,
ya da variable template'i kullanacağım,
isintegral underscore v t,
return,
yıldız x,
as,
return x,
hesabı bakın,
int e,
eşit bir 56,
iostream,
cout,
get value,
i,
tüss,
just drink,
P,
s,
what role,
kod yıldız p
eşittir adres s
cout
get value p
ikinci get value çağrısında
derleyicinin oluşturacağı kod
return yıldız x
t türü pointer türü olduğu zaman
ters yazmışız
integral kalmış ters yazmamışım da
is pointer yazacakken
is integral yazmışım
evet is pointer
underscore v
e
şimdi doğru
runtime'a bakalım
evet arkadaşlar bakın şimdi
çok güzel bir örnek daha
yani if constexpr'nin
sağladığı avantajı
anlatabilen bence
çok güzel bir örnek daha
önce şu koda bakalım
arkadaşlar şimdi bu kodda ne görüyoruz
bu kodda
dört tane
overload var
üstteki overload
hepsinin ismi aynı olduğu için
bunlar overload
biliyorsunuz normal fonksiyonlarla
fonksiyon şablonları
birbirini overload edebiliyor
en üstteki fonksiyon şablonu
ama alttakilerin hepsi
normal fonksiyon
bu durumda hatırlayın
eğer gerçek fonksiyonun
parametresiyle aynı tür ise
gönderilen argüman
aynı türden ise
gerçek fonksiyon çağrılacak
aksi halde
fonksiyon şablonundan fonksiyon üretilecek
dolayısıyla
fonksiyonların koduna bakalım
fonksiyon şablonu
to string'e çağrı yaptı
buradaki fonksiyon
string nesnesinin kendisini döndürdü
arkadaşlar
c string'i
string'e dönüştürdü
hatta hatta
buradaki fonksiyon
bu da ilginç
boolean parametreli
fakat true değer gelirse
true yazısını
bir string olarak döndürüyor
st string olarak döndürüyor
false değer gelirse
false yazısını döndürüyor
gerçekten de şimdi fonksiyon çağrılarına bakın
hatta şöyle göstersin
cztr gönderdim
arkadaşlar bu çalışacak
st string gönderdim
öyle değil mi
efendim int gönderdim
buradan fonksiyon yazılacak
double gönderdim
boolean gönderdim
bu çağrılacak
ama şimdi
bir iki
biri fonksiyon çablonu olmak üzere
üç
dört tane
fonksiyon yazdık
yani overloading'den faydalandık
öyle değil mi
ama şimdi
overloading yerine
derleyicinin compile time'da
kod seçmesini sağlayalım
template type name'de
st string
to str
parametrisi
p türünden
ne olsun
p
az önceki fonksiyonun
yapısının aynısını oluşturacağım
arkadaşlar
is convertible diye bir
meta fonksiyon var
bir türden bir türe
dönüşüm var mı
onu sınıyor
yani şöyle kullanıyor
bakın
st
is
convertible'ın
iki tane template parametrisi var
t
ikinci tür
mesela iki tane template parametrisi olsaydı bu
t türünden u türüne
dönüşüm var mı
sorusunun cevabını olacaktık
ama burada
st
string
yazarsam
neyi sınamış oluyorum
bu fonksiyonun template parametrisine karşılık gelen template argümanı olan türden
st
string
türüne
dönüşüm var mı
bakın farklı farklı meta fonksiyonlar var
böyle yazmak yerine
is
seyimi kullansaydım
bu dönüşüm değil
t türü doğrudan
string türü mü
sorusunun cevabını alacaktım
ama böyle yazarsam
arkadaşlar bu
dönüşüm var mı
sorusunun cevabını veriyor
o zaman if constexpr'de
if parantezi içine bu ifadeye koyarsam
bu arada
arkadaşlar burada constexpr bir fonksiyona çağrı da yapabilirsiniz
tabii ki
çünkü o da bir sabit ifadesi
if'in doğru kısmına girerse
string'e dönüştürülebilen bir türse
o zaman doğrudan
argüman
fonksiyonun parametre değişikliğine return ifadesi yapıyorum
ne de olsa string'e örtülü olarak dönüşüyor
else if
constexpr
e
tür
bool türü ise
bu özel bir durum
o zaman burada da
is seyimi kullanırım
stud
is seyimi
underscore ve
p türüyle
bu türü
aynı türlerse
arkadaşlar
o zaman da
burada kodlendirilecek
return
turner operatörü kullanalım yine
true
boz
eğer string'e dönüştürülebilen bir tür değilse
bu türü de değilse
o zaman buradaki statement yürütülecek
return
to
string
ee
bu kadar
arkadaşlar tabi
bundan sonra öğreneceğimiz araçlarla da birlikte kullanacağız
sadece kullanımı
bunlarla sınırlı değil
şimdi sadece bir tanışma olduğu
if constexpr'nin
compile time if'in kullanılacağı
daha ileride özellikle STL'e geçtiğimizde
bir sürü
farklı senaryolar
olacak
şimdi geriye kaldı
iki tane daha alt başlığımız
biliyorum sizi de baya bir yordu bu
tentep konusu
ama
iki üç tane daha alt başlığı alıp artık gerçekten bitireceğiz
is convertible ve
örtülü dönüşümü kontrol ediyor
evet
evet yani
örtülü dönüşüm olmazsa
true değer
vermeyecek
arkadaşlar şimdi
bir
static
assert
declaration
old
expressions
her iki konuyu da
yine belirli bir ayrıntı düzeyinde
görmemiz gerekiyor
arkadaşlar önce
static
assert
declaration
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
şimdi
assertion'ın ne olduğunu herkes hatırlıyor
c'den daha biliyorsunuz
doğrulama
assertion'ları iki kategoriye ayırdığımızı daha önce konuşmuştuk
compile time assertions
ya da static assertions
bir de
runtime
assertions
yani compile time'de yapılan doğrulamalar
ve runtime'de yapılan doğrulamalar
runtime assertions
assert makrosu ile tipik olarak
kullanılıyor
yani assert makrosu
runtime assertions'ın
temel aracı
c'de
assert başlık dosyasındaki
functional
makro'dan bahsediyorum
c'de ayrıntılı olarak
anlatmıştım
ama
compile time assertions
compile time'de yapılan doğrulamalar
arkadaşlar
arkadaşlar c'nin
yine 2011 standartıyla
c'ye de static assert
declarations
eklendi
c++'da da static assert
modern c++'da
dileklenen bir araç
static assert
arkadaşlar
bir bildirim
yani
syntax'da ne olarak
geçiyor
bir bildirim olarak
static assert
declarations
bu bildirimi
lokal düzeyde
ya da global düzeyde
yapabiliyorsunuz
hatta bir sınıfın içinde de
doğrudan yazabiliyorsunuz
yani
şunların hepsi geçerli
bir
static assert
bildirimini
syntax'ı birazdan göstereceğim
global düzeyde
yapmak
static assert
bildirimini
lokal düzeyde
yani bir fonksiyonun
içinde yapmak
hatta
static assert
bildirimini
doğrudan
arkadaşlar
bir sınıf tanımı
içinde yapmak
tabii ki burada
static assert
bildirimi
jenerik
kodlarla
kullanılmak
zorunda değil
yani ortada
bir template
olsa da
olmasa da
static assert
bildirimini
kullanabiliyorsunuz
fakat
arkadaşlar
template
kodlarla
kullanımı
tabii ki
çok daha
yaygın
şimdi
static assert
bildiriminde
normalde
syntax'ta
static assert
bildiriminin
iki tane
parametresi
olması gerekiyordu
yanlış bir
kararla
şöyle ki
genel
syntax
şöyleydi
static
assert
arkadaşlar
o anahtar
sözcükten sonra
parantez
parantezin
içine
bir
compile time
ifadesi
yani bir
constant expression
ondan sonra da
bir string
literali
böylece
derleyici
compile time
buraya dikkat
statik assert
birinci
parametresi
diyelim
ona gönderilen
sabit ifadesinin
compile time'da
true mu
false mu olduğunu
sınıyor
boolean olarak
yorumlanıyor
bu ifade
true ise
bir syntax
hatası
oluşmuyor
ama
false ise
doğrudan
bir syntax
hatası
oluşuyor
ve oluşan
syntax
hatasını
verirken
de derleyiciniz
statik assert'un
ikinci parametresi
olan
string literalini
hata mesajında
gösteriyor
hadi bir örnek verelim
arkadaşlar
mesela
izleyin
herhangi bir kodda
hatta global düzeyde
statik assert
bu benim sabit ifadem
size of
int
büyüktür
c++
17'ye kadar
string literali olan
argümanın
olması
mecburiyetti
soru ortadan
kalktı
dolayısıyla
şimdi
size of
int
must
be
greater
than
arkadaşlar
do
bakın
kodu derlediğim
zaman
static
assert
fail olmadı
çünkü ifade
doğru
ama
bu ifade
compile time'de
yanlış olsaydı
derleyici
bir syntax
hatası
verme
yükümlülüğünde
ve bu
string literalini
syntax
hatası
mesajı
olarak
bize
verecekti
bakın static
assert
failed
yani static
assertion
başarısız
olduğu anlamda
int
size
of
4'den
büyük
olmalı
dolayısıyla
compile time'de
bir kontrol
yaptırıyorum
derleyiciye
o kontrol
doğru neticelenmez
ise
doğru sonuçlanmaz
derleyicinin
syntax
hatası
vermesini
sağlıyorum
böylece
kodun
derlenmesi
için
gerekli
şartlar
oluşmadığında
erken
daha derleme
zamanında
syntax
hatası
alarak
arkadaşlar
işimi
kolaylaştırıyorum
ortada
bir template
kodun
olması
gerekmese
de
daha çok
jenerik
programlama
tarafında
kullanılacak
tekrar söylüyorum
bu bir mecburiyet
değil
mesela
bakınız
arkadaşlar
bir sınıf
şablonu
ya da
bir fonksiyon
şablonu
class
my class
şimdi özellikle
C++ 20
standardıyla
konseptler
dile eklenmediği
zaman
template'leri
constraint
etmek
kısıtlamak
için
farklı farklı
araçlar
kullanılıyordu
işte bu
araçlardan
biri de
statik
assert
mesela
ben
my class
sınıf
şablonunun
sadece
tam sayı
türleri için
oluşturulacak
specialization'ların
geçerli olmasını
istiyorsam
örneğin
my class'ın
double açılımı
gibi bir
specialization'ın
kullanılmasının
syntax
hatası
olmasını
istiyorsam
bu durumda
T türünün
tam sayı
türü
olmaması
durumunda
statik
assertion'ın
fail olmasını
sağlayabilirim
bunu yapmak da
son derece
basit
T'nin
visible olduğu
herhangi bir yerde
statik
assert
declaration'ı
koyup
yine
type
traits
kütüphanesindeki
meta fonksiyonlardan
faydalanarak
tut
is
integral
V'nin
T açılımı
şimdi görüyorsunuz
string literelerde
kullanmak zorunda da
değilim
eğer derleyiciniz
statik assert'ün
kendisine
syntax hatası
veriyorsa
o
string litereli
kullanmadığınız için
ama söylediğim gibi
seedbastas
17 ile
o kalktı
şimdi
bakınız
artık bu
statik assertion'ın
devreye girmesi için
bu tabletten
bir specialization
oluşturmam
gerekiyor
olamam kontrol
yapılacak
örneğin
my class'ın
arkadaşlar
int açılımı
ne şekilde
kullanırsam
kullanayım
bir
syntax hatası
yok
ama
my class'ın
örneğin
double açılımı
deseydim
statik assertion'a
takılacaktı
arkadaşlar
izleyin
gördüğünüz gibi
statik assertion
failed
hatta buraya
şöyle bir yazı
koysaydım
template
argument
must be
integral
gördünüz değil mi
yine
statik assertion'a
takıldı
arkadaşlar
birden fazla
statik assertion'u
da koyabilirsiniz
yani onda da
herhangi bir şekilde
bir engel yok
mesela bir
fonksiyon
şalvunu
template
pipe name
void
func
t türünden
x
tabi
template
parametresini
fonksiyon
kullanmadığım için
sadece örnek olduğu için
isim de vermiyorum
arkadaşlar
mesela
statik assert
spot
is
integral
v
e
hem tam sayı
türü
olacak t türü
ister
logic v
operatörünü
kullanın
ister
ikinci bir
statik assert
yazın
bu sefer
ikisinin de
fail olmaması
gerekecek
örneğin
size of t
büyük
bu arada
noktalı
virgül
sen tersin
bir birleşin
yani noktalı
virgül
olmak zorunda
çünkü bu da
bir declaration
bu durumda
bu fonksiyon
şablonundan
kod üretilebilmesi
için
t türünün
hem tam sayı
türü olması
gerekecek
hem de
aynı zamanda
size of
değerinin de
2'den
büyük olması
gerekecek
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
işte burada
template
parametrelerini
constraint
etmenin
yollarından
biri bu
ama şimdi
farklı yollar
arasındaki
farklara da
dikkat edelim
mesela
burada
template argümanını
ben
constraint ediyorum
ama
onun için
bu template'in
seçilmesi ve
bundan
kod üretilmesi
gerekiyor
yani
overload
resolution'a
girecek
ondan sonra
static
assertion
kontrol edilecek
dolayısıyla
zaten
bunun seçilmiş
olması gerekiyor
bu kontrolün
yapılması için
ama daha sonra
öğreneceğimiz örneğin
sphineye teknikleri
böyle değil
biraz bahsetmiştim
sphineyden
sphineyde ise
constraint
var ama
arkadaşlar
substitution
failure
error olduğunda
overload
setten
çıkartıyor
dolayısıyla
compile time'da
kod seçimine de
yardımcı oluyor
şimdi compile time'da
kod seçimi için
zaten 3-4 tane
tipik araç var
bunların bir kısmına
değindik
bir kısmına
hiç değinmedik
araçlardan biri
sphiney
uzun uzun
incelenmesi gereken
bir konu
bununla compile time'da
kod seçtirebiliyorum
derleyiciye
o kod ya da bu kod
ikincisi
şüphesiz
if
constexpr
statik if
bir de
bizim
henüz
hiç değinmediğimiz
ileride
vakit bulursak
tabi
bu kadar çok
konumuz var ki
ayrıntılı
görebileceğimiz
hack dispatch
dediğimiz
teknik var
tabi
bir de
c++20 ile
gelen
konsept
ve konseptler
ve konsept kütüphanesi
bunlarla
ne yapma
şansına
sahibiz
compile time'da
derleyiciye
kod seçtirme
şansına
sahibiz
non-type
parametrelerle
ilgili de
tabi ki
arkadaşlar
statik
asort
kullanabilirsiniz
mesela
template type
name t
stud
size t
n
class
array
şimdi
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
dizilerin
array'de
non-type
parametreye
karşılık
argüman
en az
10 olması
gereksin
yani dizinin
beri boyutun
üstünde
olması
gereksin
mesela
sınıfın
belki de
şöyle bir
veri elemanı
var
ma
n
şöyle
constraint
edebilirim
değil mi?
statika
search
n
büyüktür
ya da büyük
eşit
size
must be
greater
than
mesela
array'in
int
virgül
specialization'da
bir problem
çıkmayacak
ama örneğin
array'in
int virgül
specialization'ı
oluşturmak
istersem
statik
assertion'a
takılacak
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet
özellikle meta fonksiyonlar
statik assertion'larla birlikte
çok sık kullanıyor
mesela bakınız
birçok sınıf şablonunda
şablonun
template parametresinin
bir sınıfla
karşılanması
isteniyor
ve o sınıfın
belirli özelliklere
sahip olması
isteniyor
mesela copy
constructible
olması
move
constructible
olması
ya da
move
constructor'ının
no
except
olması
gibi
bu koşullar
sağlanmadığında
eğer bir
syntax hatası
oluşturmak
isterseniz
yine o meta fonksiyonları
kullanabilirsiniz
mesela
my class
sınıfı için
arkadaşlar
my class'ın
argümanı olan
türün
default
constructible
copy
not
constructible
vesaire
olması
gerekiyorsa
buraya
bir
statik
assert
declaration
koyup
girildiğiniz
create'i
seçebilirsiniz
örneğin
stut
is
default
constructible
ve
p
bakın bu basit
örnekte bile
struct
net
şimdi
default
constructible
dolayısıyla
my class'ın
net
açılımı
bir
syntax
hatası
oluşturmayacak
yani
static
assertion
takılmadı
ama
net
int
arkadaşlar
şimdi
static
assertion
takıldı
int
parametreli
bir
constructor
oluşturduğum
için
ne oldu
default
constructible
olma
niteliğini
kaybetti
default
constructible
olmadığı
için
syntax
hatası
oluştu
peki
şimdi
o zaman
statika
search'ın
ne
onun hakkında
bilgi edindik
variadic
template'lere
biraz
baktık
orada
bazı
eksiklerimiz
var
onları
dolduracağız
arkadaşlar
şimdi
yine
c++
17 ile
dile eklenen
fold
ifadelerine
katlama
biraz
bakalım
yine
biraz
karmaşık
bir konu
variyatik
parametre
paketlerine
sahip
fonksiyon
şablonlarında
ya da
sınıf
şablonlarında
kullanacağımız
araçlardan
biri de
c++
plus
standart
ile
dile eklenen
arkadaşlar
fold
expressions
dediğimiz
ifadeler
önce bunlar
ne işe yarıyor
bir kafamızda
canlandıralım
arkadaşlar
bunlar
parametre
paketinin
yine
önceden
belirlenmiş
bir şekilde
expand
edilmesini
sağlıyorlar
ama
doğrudan
zaten
bunlara
karşılık
gelen
kurallar
var
dolayısıyla
pratik bir
şekilde
hatta
şimdi
şaşıracaksınız
daha önce
yazdığımız
bazı
kodlar
fold
ifadeleriyle
katlama
çok daha
kolay şekilde
yazılabilecek
o zaman
genel
başlığımız
fold
expressions
önce
biraz
sentakstan
bahsedeceğiz
ve
daha sonra
kullanım
avantajları
bize ne
sağlıyor
ne şekilde
kullanıyoruz
onlardan
bahsedeceğiz
arkadaşlar
yine maalesef
çok geniş
bir konu
yani
3 saat
4 saat
5 saat
fold
ifadesi
anlatsak
yine de
konuşmamız
gereken
alt başlıklar
olabilir
ama ben
belirli ve
ayrıntı
düzeyinde
tutmak
zorundayım
şimdi
öncelikle
fold
ifadelerini
derleyici
diyorum
dilin
standartı
iki kategoriye
ayırıyorum
bir
unary
fold
expressions
iki
binary
fold
expressions
yani
bir fold
ifadesi
arkadaşlar
ya
unary
fold
olacak
ya da
binary
fold
olacak
ikisinin
arasındaki
farkı
birazdan
göreceğiz
unary
fold
ve
binary
fold
bunlar da
yine
kendi içinde
right
fold
ve left
olarak
ikiye
ayrılacak
yani
unary
right
fold
ve
unary
left
fold
binary
ifadeleri
de
yine
binary
right
fold
binary
left
fold
olarak
ikiye
ayrılacak
sadece
belirli bir süre dinlememiz
gerekiyor
yavaş yavaş
konuya
gireceğiz
arkadaşlar
bir kere
fold expression
variadic
parametre paketleriyle ilgili
yani ortada bir parametre paketi yoksa
variadic bir template yoksa
fold ifadesinin kullanılması mümkün değil
fold ifadeleri
variadic templateler için geçerli
arkadaşlar
önce
unary
fold
ile başlayalım
bir unary
fold ifadesi
parantez içinde yazılan bir ifade
buraya dikkat
parantez
sentaksın bir bileşimi
yani parantezi koymak zorundasınız
buradaki parantez
öncelik parantezi değil
arkadaşlar
parantezin içinde
bir fonksiyon şablonu olsun
fonksiyonun template parametre paketi
diyelim ki
toplama işlemini yaptıracak
bir fonksiyon şablonu
es
aks
tabii ki her zaman olduğu gibi
ne olabilir
bu
referans olabilir
fonksiyon parametre paketindeki parametreler
referans olmayabilir
const olabilir olmayabilir
onları konuştuk
arkadaşlar
bir fold ifadesi nasıl oluşturuyorum
bakın
parantez içinde
hangi operatör üstünde
fold işlemi yapılacaksa
fold işlemi bir operatör üstünde yapılmak zorunda
o operatörü yazıyorsunuz
arkadaşlar bu operatör
binary bir operatör
ve buraya dikkat
binary operatörün
bir operanda olarak
parametre paketini
fakat diğer operatör olarak
ellipsis
spoken'ını kullanıyorsunuz
yavaş yavaş yavaş yavaş yavaş yavaş yavaş
yavaş yavaş yavaş yavaş yavaş
buraya kadar
her şey net değil mi
bu bir
fold expression
unery fold expression
ellipsis
binary operatörümüzün solid sağ 아니야
Buna unary left fold diyoruz.
Eğer şöyle olsaydı, arks operatör artı, elipsiz burada olsaydı, bu da right fold.
Şimdi ben ilk dile eklendiğinde bu ikisini hep birbiriyle karıştırıyordum çoğu kişi gibi.
Hep şöyle aklımda tutmaya başlamıştım.
Elipsiz operatörün solundaysa o zaman left fold, sağındaysa right fold.
O zaman bu unary left fold mu right fold mu?
Unary right fold.
Şöyle olsaydı, arkadaşlar söyleyin, unary left fold olacaktı.
Bu operatör sizin seçtiğiniz herhangi bir binary operatör olabilir.
Örneğin toplama olabilir, çarpma olabilir, bölme olabilir, büyüktür olabilir.
Ve buradaki arkadaşlar, elipsiz bu şekilde bulunmak zorunda.
Peki, şimdi derleyici bunun için nasıl bu kod üretecek?
Arkadaşlar son derece basit.
Derleyici fold expression olan ifadeyi aslında şuna dönüştürüyor unary right fold için.
eğer left fold ise, bu fonksiyonun parametrelerinin isimleri olsaydı P1, P2, P3 diye
P1 artı P2, buraya dikkat.
Left fold olduğu için soldan parantez içine alınacak.
Artı P3, arkası ters, böyle gidiyor.
Artı P4, anlaşıldı mı?
Dolayısıyla öyle bir ifade oluşacak ki, bu ifade zaten bütün argümanların toplama anlamına gelecek.
Böylece mesela sum isimli fonksiyonu, böyle basit bir şekilde bu ifadeyi doğrudan fonksiyonun return ifadesi yaparak implemente etmiş olacağız.
Buraya kadar takip edebildik mi?
Arkadaşlar bu arada bir şeye de dikkat.
Burada parametrelerin türünün aynı olması gerekmiyor değil mi?
Dolayısıyla fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri türü olarak, bu örnekte tabii farklı şekilde de kullanılabilir.
Auto return type kullandım.
Çünkü örneğin int ile double'ı toplarsam sonuç double olacak.
Burada template argümanları hepsi aynı türden de olabilir, farklı türden de olabilir.
Mesela bakınız, tabii noktalı virgülü de koyalım.
Arkadaşlar izleyin, return, return diyorum, main fonksiyonu,
1, 2, 4, 3.76.
O zaman buradaki ifade, 2 artı 4 artı 3.76 olacak.
Bu ifadenin türü double olacak.
Aslında biz geri dönüş değeri türü double olan bir fonksiyonun kodunu yazdırmış olacağız.
See out.
Sabırla izlemeye devam.
Bunlar çok basit örneklerdir.
Arkadaşlar bakın şimdi, herkes dikkatli izliyor.
Burada left fault olması ile right fault olması arasındaki fark ne?
Fonksiyonun kodu böyle olmak yerine,
şöyle olsaydı args artı,
bu durumda da derleyicinin oluşturduğu kod şöyle olacaktı.
Diyelim ki fonksiyonun 5 tane parametre değişkeni var ya da 4 tane var.
return, return, p1 artı p2 artı p3 artı p4 artı p5.
Ama parantezler sağdan.
Örneğin böyle.
Şimdi diyebilirsiniz ki,
en hecatı bir şey fark etmez.
Çok şey fark eder.
Örneğin auto return type kullandığınız zaman,
fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerinin türü farklı olabilir.
Ya da veri kaybı olabilir.
Ya da olmayabilir.
Ya da duruma göre hiçbir fark olmayabilir.
Mesela şu örneğe bakalım arkadaşlar.
Soru.
String.
Ya da string.
Name.
Summit.
Sam.
Name.
Summit isimli arkadaşım da var.
Shen.
Gel.
Söyleyin bakalım.
Sertaks hatası olur mu, olmaz mı?
Cevap.
Bu binary left fault mu?
Unary left fault mu?
Right fault mu?
Cevap yuneri right fault.
Şöyle olsaydı.
Bravo Mermetcan Bey bu arada.
Bakınız.
Bu.
Yuneri.
Left fault olacaktı.
Fonksiyonun.
Geri dönüş değerini.
Yazdıralım.
Eğer bir semtaks hatası olmazsa.
Gördüğünüz gibi toplama operatörünün operatörünün operatörü aslında fonksiyonun parametre değişkenliğinin değerleri.
Yuneri left fault olmak yerine yuneri right fault yapalım.
Arx artı.
Bu durumda derlediğim size neden sentaks hatası oldu?
Hemen hata mesajına bakmadan kim söyleyecek?
Derleyicinin bravo bravo bravo.
Konstruşar Yıldız iki tane pointer'ı toplayacak bir kod üretecek değil mi?
Bravo.
Dolayısıyla duruma göre yuneri left fault ile yuneri right fault birbirinden farklı sonuçlar üretebilir.
Mesela bakın.
Çok güzel bir örnek.
Auto div arkadaşlar.
Ve fonksiyonun kodu şöyle olsun.
Return.
Gördüğü.
Arx.
Yuneri left fault mu?
Yuneri right fault mu?
Yuneri left fault.
Çünkü elipsiz solda olduğuna göre yuneri left fault.
Yani soldan parantez almaya başlayacak.
Hangi operatör üstüne yuneri left fault?
Bölme operatörü üstüne.
Öyle değil mi?
Kesinlikle.
Arkadaşlar bakın şimdi.
Ben bu durumda div fonksiyonunu değil mi dedik?
Div fonksiyonunu şöyle çağırırsam.
500.
Efendim 50.
Bu değerleri önceden seçtim.
5, 2.
Div fonksiyonunun hangi değeri döndüreceğini söyleyebilir misiniz?
500 bölü 50, 10.
10 bölü 5, 2.
2 bölü 2, 1.
Yani fonksiyonunun geri dönüşü değeri 1 olur değil mi?
Ama left fault yerine right fault olsaydı.
Arks.
Bu durumda parantezler sağdan olacak.
Yani right associative gibi davranacak.
5 bölü 2, 2.
50 bölü 2, 25.
500 bölü 25, 20 mi olur?
20 olur herhalde değil mi?
Şimdi fonksiyonunun geri dönüş değerine bakalım.
Arkadaşlar 20 olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Şimdi burada önemli yine notlar.
Herhangi bir binary operatörü üstüne ne yapabiliriz?
Arkadaşlar fold ifadesi oluşturabiliriz.
Özellikle idiomatik kodların önemli bir kısmı virgül operatörüyle oluşturman neler?
Foldlar.
Yani virgül de bir binary operatör değil mi?
Virgül operatörü içinde ne oluşturabilirim?
Bir unary left fault ya da unary right fault oluşturabilirim.
Bu arada sadece fonksiyon şamlulu olması gibi bir zorunluluk da yok.
Mesela şu örneğe bakın.
Bu bir değişken şablonda olabilir.
Template
Int
N
ConstExpr
Int
Tam
Buraya dikkat edin.
Arkadaşlar bu
Variable Template
Sentaksı
Variable Template'de template parametresi parametre paketti.
Önce konuşmuştuk parametre paketi olması
fonksiyon şablonu ya da sınır şablonu olma mecburiyetini getirmiyor.
Eşittir.
Fold Expression
Artı
Vars
N
Böylece
Örneğin ben
Sam'ın
2, 5, 7, 9 açılımı olan değişkeni kullanırsam
template argümanlarının toplamı olan hangi sabit olacak?
7, 14, 23 sabit olacak.
Bu mesela 23 sabit.
Bakın gösteriyor da compile time de belli oluyor değil mi?
Takip edebildik mi?
Ya da şuna bakın.
Başka bir örnek.
ConstExpr
Int
Sam değil de bu sefer
SamSquare olsun.
Ve
Yine
Yüneri
LevFold olsun.
Fakat
Buradaki
İfade
N
Çarpı
İfadesi olsun.
Bu durumda da
Derleyici
Sırısıyla ne yapacak?
Arkadaşlar
Yine parantez içinde
Toplama operatörü
Kullanılacak.
Ama bu kez
Her biri için
N
Çarpı
İfadesi kullanılacak.
Yani
Sam değil de
Örneğin
SamSquare'in
İki beş üç açılımı
Olsaydı
İkinin karesi
Artı beşin karesi
Artı üçün karesi
Yirmi beş
Dokuz daha
Otuz dört
Dört daha
Otuz sekiz
Sabiti
Elde edilecekti.
Yani bu
Otuz sekiz
Sabiti olacak.
Göstermiyor ama
Şöyle yazabiliriz.
ConstExpr
Otu
X
Eşiktir.
Başka bir hata yoksa
X'in değerini
Diğerde bir parantez
Almış
Yedinci satır
Evet şurada bir parantez eksik
Onun için
Tamam.
Şimdi ne eksik
Şimdi de
Şuradaki noktalı
Yirmi eksik
Tamam.
Şimdi bakan
Gerçekten
Değerin
Otuz sekiz olduğunu
Görüyorsunuz.
Arkadaşlar
Patlama ifadelerine bir giriş yaptık.
Aşağı yukarı şöyle bir yarım saat
Kırk beş dakika daha
Fold Expressions konusunda konuşacağız.
Bir iki tane daha küçük başlık olacak ama
En azından şöyle söyleyebiliriz.
Artık haftadan
Bir dahaki haftadan itibaren
Uzunca bir süre
Konumuz
STL olacak
Standart
Template
Library'dir.
Template konusunda eksiklerimiz var mı?
Var.
Doğal olarak
Çok geniş bir konu.
Ama artık o eksikleri
STL'i incelerken
Yavaş yavaş
Kapatırız.
Çünkü önümüzde
Kursun belki
En uzun bölümü olan
STL
Standart
Template
Library'i var.
C++'ın
Standart
Kütüphanesi'ni
Artık detaylı olarak
Bir
Görmeye
Başlayacağız.
Maalesef
Benim yüzümden
Bu hafta bir ders yapıldı.
İnşallah
İleride de bunu
STL bitince
Kurs bitiyor sanırım.
Hayır.
STL bitince
Maalesef
Kurs bitmiyor.
Başka konular da var.
Yani STL haricinde
Konular da var.
Ben Necat Ergin.
Derse katıldığınız için
Teşekkür ediyorum.
Bir dahaki hafta
Görüşmek üzere.
Herkese
İyi akşamlar diliyorum.
Hoşçakalın
Değerli arkadaşlar.